anh alo
à à
anh alo chào các bạn
anh alo alo alo
ừ ừ
em về rồi Mình ở Sài Gòn tác khá khá
nhiều bạn ở trong Server này
số lượng bạn ở trong server
cái mình tự tạo ra này để mà làm đồ án
đấy nó chẳng thấy ít hơn so với việc ta
sẽ vô này cả kinh p kinh tế bây giờ đây
giờ lên những món xuống khá nhiều nhưng
thực ra là mình cũng lại phá trong việc
tao tất cả mọi người như thế
Ừ nhưng mà thôi thì
chỉ với mục đích là kiểu dạng là những
người vào đấy với mục đích chủ yếu là
học Ngân hàng ra lại
ra học của mình hết chứ không phải là
học bình thường còn nếu hợp lệ vừa mình
hoàn toàn có thể và kính khác bởi vì cái
cái đăng ký vào kênh đấy cũng như đảm
bảo vào server đấy thì chắc là
để học những kiểu đền làm được giống
hiểu đăng ký để nhận in ra thông
Ừ anh nên là mình nghĩ rồi tắm chấp nhận
việc Farm đấy
anh khác alo alo alo không nghe gì à
khi khát mắt bé đợi Đức
alo alo ai bây giờ to hơn đôi này gọi
điếc tai luôn
để đưa tay chưa
anh alo
Ừ mình đang đeo tai nghe mình nghe được
rõ mình nói gì nên là mình còn cảm thấy
vừa rồi hả rất là to rồi
ừ ừ
à à Nhưng mà buổi hôm nay thì à nhưng
các bạn thấy là mình sẽ chấm mình chấm
Xem chuyện xem thêm sửa xóa ở từng nhóm
A và
các bạn Nhưng mà trước đấy thì mình cũng
định tâm sự khá nhiều đã tranh thủ bữa
mày dân sự bùng cháy sản phẩm sự là gì
cả
ngày Xin lỗi mấy ông Nếu ông ấy ông vào
sớm cũng chả nhận được gì cả buổi hôm
nay vốn à
Mình mình đang định tính thì như mình
bảo đến buổi thứ bảy sẽ đỡ buổi không
không phải học thì mấy mà chỉ là xem xem
mình chấm như nào gọi Chắc là bây giờ
kèm 2 là tâm sự nữa được hiệu cuối tuần
ní kiểu thoải mái tí nha
thứ hai mình có lưu lại vài được sót của
của YouTube mình sẽ cho các bạn xem sau
đó thì các bạn Cảm nhận trước đã rồi
mình mới phát biểu đúng
thì mình nghĩ là thỉnh thoảng kiểu như
này cũng hay ờ không biết các bạn thấy
như thế nào Các bạn hãy góp ý Mình nói
chung mà tính Linh thì
bạn mình không ai có cái câu đó là
thì các bạn không ngờ thấy được cái
mụn hay là vết bẩn ở trên mặt của bạn
trừ khi các bạn soi gương đúng không ạ
nhưng mà các bạn không phải luôn luôn
soi gương được sẽ phải có người khác
nhắc nhát bạn đấy thì mình mong có người
luôn có người nhắc mình là mình đang làm
cái gì đó Nấu bịch Hai đang làm gì đó
sai để mình con xưa nên là các bạn có
nhắc mình thoải mái hồi góp ý gì đó Kể
cả việc
có người ở từng nói là tôi nhạt hạ hay
các thứ thì tôi cũng Hồi đấy tôi tự ái
ấy bởi vì Đấy là bạn tạm tôi 8 mà
bạn gái mình tán bạn ấy kêu mình nhạt
đấy
Ừ thì à thì lúc đấy tôi sẽ làm gì giống
như là tôi sẽ không phải là tôi tủi thân
thứ tự ái rồi tôi sẽ không rời gian khác
nữa mà lúc đấy tôi sẽ đầu tiên thì tôi
phải hỏi thêm một vài người nữa sẽ là là
có đúng thế là không hay là bạn kia
chẳng qua là bạn ghét mình lên mà nói
thế thứ hai là mình mình phải sửa những
cái gì không ạ thì mình sẽ hỏi những
người xung quanh để xem và mình nên phải
cần chỉnh sửa những cái gì
à à
Ừ thôi Nói chung là bây giờ mình sẽ cho
các bạn xem
một cái một vài cái video shop mà hôm
trước nửa đêm tự nhiên mình xem được với
cùng thì mình kể cái này nó nào dùng Tik
Tok với ông ạ xem xong nghiện
Đợi tí tôi nghĩ à Samsung history lại nó
có cái rung lên à
à à
khi Toàn bộ bằng tiếng anh ấy nhé Đây là
mấy ông đấy bây giờ thực ra là hơi mệt
cho mấy ông làm à
ở những kiểu kèm tiếng anh một tí không
biết là cái phụ đề là chọn không
Ừ để tự động dịch nghĩa còn chết nữa để
tôi để tự động riêng cho em nha ở
Mecca special to use of today and
species
transcends
neww anaconda What Makes You Beautiful
for compelling yourself in the trash
talk about more people think that talk
anymore live in the Sweet Little
Einstein come out because what I want to
do your way you are the way or are in my
fav and defined in Style In Use Today
Thank you to
Ê mày cứ lợn chó này rất là ngắn để nói
sót nhé
Ừ mình thì thứ cái là mình từng khó chịu
khi mà người ta mở cái vé sừng lên xem
cái gì đó người ta cứ cư cứ đau lại liên
tục ở giữa của một cái video Mình đang
xem rồi tự như táo lại đó để mà Nêu cảm
nghĩ gì đó
bởi video lấy bị Chưa xem bao giờ nên
thành ra là kiểu nó bị ngắt quãng người
khác khó chịu thế là thực ra khi mà mình
thường mình sẽ ngược lại kiểu đấy là
mình sẽ cho mọi người xem hết đã xong
rồi mình mới nói đâu ạ Nó sẽ khác một tí
Ừ thế có làm việc làm việc cùng anh ạ
Ừ cái này mấy người đấy phát âm tiếng
Anh có vẻ chuẩn chắc là vừa rồi dịch khá
ổn Đấy
Ừ Thế có lên làm việc cùng anh em sẽ
Vina favourite ceremony In just some
more interest rate live and work people
understand I love you want What was
gatherings from work Of America systema
folate Kali and to receive the of Evil
Love and life well with you on any level
65 Atlas that supports The North Face
surge II
trò chơi ngày hay phết
à à
a Metal Grow là hàng phát hành
a What is play nảy sinh ý
ý tả cái này nó chỉ có mà không tự động
dịch Ok What is play lái xe bị xuyên VND
Bieber dress party is Vietnamese and
Western City Steve Jobs want to phanta
phân dalspa phim don't I heart you have
tried to work on not to forget me not to
get rid of all
specials and Real Life I
Ừ cái này Ở nhà toàn là bởi vì tên của
nó nói nó cải ta là con gái nói thôi
ý em nói cái này nhé Xong rồi mình sẽ
phát biểu ạ
are you cannot make
a What is play
Mình đi quanh Hà Tĩnh
này tôi sẽ có mày xem nha
are you can not make Anyone have What UK
Anh Thu Thảo và với Make Yourself ping
anh dantri very important their job
leaves your daunting for love ceren is
what most importantly
learn to breed Dragon à
em hãy nghe tin nhắn thế thôi và
Không không thích cái này là của kính
khác Inverter
và cái bình luận của cái cái bài này
đúng đúng với mình luận lại rất là hai
này đó là kiểu
Ừ thứ nhất là cái kể kênh này
nó khác với nhiều kênh khắp nó không nói
về việc là nữ Nữ Quyền như thế nào
vì nó không đổ tại cho hoàn cảnh này cái
thứ truyền cảm hứng này đây và
nó không nói việc kiểu nữ bây giờ rồi Nữ
Quyền đang cầm đồ tại Mọi thứ cái thứ
thứ về vấn đề của họ mà đây là cách mà
họ tự dậy tự gặp phần đây để giải quyết
vấn đề như thế nào
Ê bà câu chốt rất là hai này vào kênh
này không không không giới hạn dành cho
mỗi con gái rồi mình xem mà không ạ Các
bạn cũng xem các bạn thấy là nó khá là
đúng cho mọi dối chẳng phải cả nam và nữ
mình thấy cái người khá ổn là tiếng Anh
cũng tiếng Anh vừa rồi thì đương nhiên
là tiếng Anh ngoài tiếng Anh chuyên
ngành thành ra được nhiều ông mà kiểu
kèm thì anh cơ bản thì nghe mấy cái đấy
Người ta nói ngang Nữa tất cả hơi khó
hiểu tí nhưng đại khái ý vừa rồi thì các
bạn đều nổi đều xem qua đều họ đều nói
về cuộc sống
nói về là mình nên sống như nào nhưng
sống kiểu tự tin Hãy là chính mình vân
vân và đại lượng Hãy lựa chọn ngoãn cuộc
sống ở
vì cuộc sống ở của sự lựa chọn thôi
ông ngoại nó nào giống như là kiểu à
từ điển hình là các bạn Các bạn có thể
chọn Xem kênh của mình hoặc là bây giờ
ngồi chơi game người đi chơi không ạ Bạn
bạn thể chọn xem cái khác được
và mỗi việc lựa chọn đấy nó sẽ dẫn đến
một cái gì đó đúng không nói chuyện mà
các bạn cả ngày không làm gì Thôi tự
nhiên các bạn giàu nóng hoặc ít nhất là
các bạn để chọn đánh đề Đánh lô cũng là
một cách
Nhưng mấy ra đó lựa chọn không ạ
a và và nếu mà
nhiều bạn đã từng nói với mình
đó là
không biết mình thường nói các bạn chưa
Nhưng mà kiểu tôi mình đã từng kiểu Lâu
lâu không gặp lại bạn cũ ấy rồi cậu 125
gặp lại là sự bạn cấp 2 cấp 3 là bạn ấy
thì
các bạn hoa cà chỉ đơn giản là thằng bạn
thân nhưng mà vẫn không 150 liên lạc bỏ
đều bà ở tôi là kiểu buổi sách sao mày
khác thế
thì ra là nếu nếu mà nói với ngoại hình
thì sẽ nào tôi chẳng khác gì cả Tôi
trông bọn trẻ con đi Thế trông kiểu vẫn
mặt bụng nó giữ với Vân đấy nhưng mà vợ
toàn bà mày khác theo kiểu là sự nghiệp
khác này hồi trước mặt cả tình cảm khác
nữa Nhưng thì hơi xa quá nhưng đại khái
thì
khi mọi thứ tôi có vẻ tiến triển đấy hội
trong khi đó đi Khi mà hỏi mấy người đấy
thì mình gửi Bỏ rồi chắc ốm lắm lập gia
đình
cái đấy cái khác nhất của nó còn không
thì nó không có gì đổi mới lắm trong năm
vừa rồi
Ừ Anh nghe là kiểu và rất hiểu đứa bảo
là làm nào để mở kiểu thay đổi cuộc sống
những điển hình khá hơn thì tốt hơn Nói
chung là nó thấy cuộc sống hiện tại đang
cả nhà Hải Vân Vân tất cả thì chỉ đơn
giản là vì nó lại thay đổi con người đôi
khi bị ngại thay đổi ở và và kiểu Họ
không làm cái gì đó mới mỗi ngày
Ừ anh ra là kiểu không
vì họ không có lựa chọn mới mỗi ngày họ
sống đi sống lại mỗi ngày cuộc sống biểu
giống hiểu thế đi ăn ở quán quen chỉ gặp
những người quen đúng ạ làm những cái
việc và mình làm được là môi
anh không thử với thứ lạ không ạ Không
có đưa ra những lựa chọn khác
thì cuộc sống các bạn sẽ quay con như
thế và các bạn sẽ không phát triển được
bản thân thêm không ạ anh ngày nào cũng
nói chuyện với một người làm sao mà
không có thể phát triển bản thân thêm
trừ khi ở người kia đi Nói chuyện người
khác nữa thì ông học hỏi được thêm
ở ngoại ô
đã có nhiều người đang sống cuộc sống mà
kiểu hẳn một năm luôn đấy mà nó giống
hệt nhau OK thì mày ông có thể đổi tại
bây giờ giao dịch không Đi chơi không
được không giao lưu với Văn được nhưng
mà năm vừa rồi của tôi mới là 5A ở ít
thay đổi nhất của tôi Còn tất cả các năm
trước của tôi thì tôi thay đổi nhiều Cực
a cho
thái độ cao sự nghiệp này cả mối quan hệ
vân vân quen nhiều người hơn nhiều người
biết đến hơn 2 da Vân
anh nói chung là các bạn là
à mà bị ngại thay đổi ngay từ hồi mà còn
anh trẻ
anh tí thử ca về sau Thứ nhất về sau sự
sẽ nó là sẽ là quá muộn Nếu các bạn muốn
thay đổi gì đó về giống như Jack Ma ban
mai từng bờ kia tuổi trẻ thì các bạn
được phép phá sản được phép lưu lĩnh gì
đó Còn khi về già rồi chỉ các bạn không
được phép làm điều đấy nữa ngoạn 75 gì
còn thời gian để mà thay đổi được gì đó
làm cho một tuổi trẻ các bạn có thể khám
phá đủ thứ Xem ngành nào phù hộ mình mọi
thứ phù hợp với mình cứ
khi bạn
ngã ở đâu đừng nên được đúng không ạ Còn
già rồi ngã chắc đừng nên được già Đây
tôi nói chỉ cần đến 30 40 thì các bạn sẽ
phải cân nhắc trong Mọi quyết định của
mình hơn
khi con
còn tuổi trẻ này thì cho các bạn các bạn
mắc sai lầm thoải mái đứng nhiên là vẫn
chẳng ai bảo là muốn mình bị sai lầm gà
nhưng mà ở nhưng mà luôn tự an ủi bản
thân đó là Hà sai lầm bây giờ có bài học
bây giờ còn hơn là về già họ mới bị dính
bao nhiêu lần mình thường ai ổn hả nổi
bản thân thế
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ hoàn toàn thoải mái khi
mà kiểu không bị đương nhiên là cũng nên
rút ra bài học nhá không Vậy à Thôi kệ
kiểu đen tôi Tôi từng nói là tôi không
Bơ đổi tại cho số phận không còn chuyện
đen đủi đây cả Ừ nó là do mình đúng là
mình bị ngu hai mình bị gì đó mới đưa
những quyết định sai lầm như thế
a cho tôi đang nói hơi kiểu dạy đời một
tí nhưng mà Bởi vì chính những video rồi
mình thấy nó cũng cũng đời thứ ra tôi
không thích xem video Đời trên mạng đâu
Tôi đang thấy mấy ông ngồi ở đây nghe
thì nếu mà cảm thấy không lọt vai lắm
nhưng chắc chắn nó sẽ đến một cái dễ đồ
gì đó và khó chịu nhưng mà
nhưng mà ý của tôi thì thì mày ông cũng
hiểu rồi bởi vì à Tôi thấy nhiều bạn ở
đây chủ yếu vẫn có thể đang trên trường
theo cả lại mong đông như một trò đùa
trước số phận tương lai của mình đi về
đâu ai ai cũng sẽ thế
em thậm chí nhiều đứa bạn của tôi ra
trường rồi bây giờ vẫn thế bởi vì bởi vì
họ nhất là không tin tưởng bạn hơn mình
Thứ hai họ sợ mắc cái gì đó Sợ đủ thứ
em sợ thì là tốt Sợ là tốt nhé nhưng mà
sợ không làm thì là giỏ
em sợ xong rồi vượt qua nỗi sợ sẽ khiến
cho mình trưởng thành tại nó như thế
trưởng thành hơn này và sự và kiểu dạng
mà thành con người từng trải đàn thôi
vừa rồi có ông bảo tôi là gặp
nói Nói hay thôi có duyên khối em đổ Vân
Vân Vân trả quà tôi tôi sợ và tôi chuẩn
bị cái thứ thứ trước gia sư ở bây giờ
này phải sợ nói chuyện trước mấy ông ấy
ông cười này tôi thực ra tội ông bị thế
thành ra là tôi sẽ phải chuẩn bị trước
để để không không bị như thế nữa đúng ạ
Ừ nhưng mà kiểu gì cũng sẽ có nhiều nốt
vào chỗ bị ngáo mà em thấy rồi
đi ra chưa nói được cái câu gì đó hiểu
sai
Ừ nhưng mà anh sẽ có lúc bị
bị sai lầm thôi miễn là nó không Không
đến nỗi là bị ảnh hưởng quá nhiều
và mình có thể gỡ gạt được thì thoải mái
à à
Ha ha cái vợ giàu à
Cưới vợ dầu giờ sự có một em xinh em vừa
sinh là hai đủ mọi thứ mà mà vẫn và giàu
nữa
khi mở yêu ông
ông có nghĩ lại là em về chặng chọn đúng
không
đợi tí con chó sủa mèo ú
à à
thi đấu tôi không mày con chó đâu Nó sủa
gì lạ rồi mà nhóm xổ con mèo
khi nào được nó rồi mik nhé ạ
ừ ừ
ạ
bây giờ
đấy tôi tôi em hỏi rồi đấy bây giờ sử có
một bạn nào đó hot girl xinh hỏi đủ thứ
đảm đang cho ngồi đảm đang không dấu vân
vân vân thì
anh mãi yêu không
Ừ ông cũng sẽ có tự trừ khi là ông kiểu
nghĩ ông con người rồi hoàn hảo lắm rồi
em vừa xứng đôi với bạn ấy thì không sao
còn nếu mà giờ sử mà ông không cảm thấy
mình như thế
Ừ đúng thì nó lại quá sai ông nghĩa là
kiểu em này lừa mình à ngon Em này mình
đang ở trong cái trò chơi thử thách của
chị chuyện truyền hình thực tế nào à sẽ
vân vân
ô hay tự nhiên số mình may à
anh đúng không ạ
ờ ờ
thì thì mấy ông cũng để chắc chắn nó sẽ
kiểu ngồi nghĩ lại nghĩ khá nhiều làn no
đủ kiểu đúng ạ thì bây giờ làm thế nào
em chuyển nhà nó bây giờ mình cảm thấy
mình phải xứng đáng
Ừ thì mình mới không được nghĩ kiểu gì
nữa
à à
Ừ
thôi Tôi từng nói là laptop của tôi
không có cam nhé mắt tôi laptop tôi tôi
thể để ở Dĩ Vãng còn chẳng có cam ạ
nhưng thực ra là tôi và thực ra là tôi
cũng
gọi nhà tôi đang trong bộ dạng khẩu ở
nhà theo phong cách thoải mái thành ra
lời cho mấy ông chẳng có gì xem cả và
thời gian một phần nữa tội mùa đông mấy
ông tập trung vào thì con nhìn cái màn
hình được Cảm nhận trong hơi khô khan
thật nhưng mà lúc mà dậy đúng mà cốt thì
mấy ông nên tập trung vào cốt hãi vì
nhìn vào mà tôi
anh ngồi
ừ ừ
khoa học điên à Hà Nội đang lạnh lắm
không cần đùi cởi trần gì cả Tôi đang
mặc à Ở Chắc là quảng cáo luôn Tôi đang
mặc toàn đồ của Uniqlo đồ của Nhật nó
giữ nhiệt kháng ẩm cho da mặc cái áo áo
Gọi a lot Nếu mà dùng từ nó sẽ là áo lót
cho nam áo kiểu
giữ nhiệt nhật quần cũ mà nó Quân quần
lót Nhưng mà thực ra nó còn lại quần
chân còn
em trả
bộ quần áo
Quảng cáo bởi vì a Tôi thấy em mặc đúng
mỗi cái này hội ấy mãi
vì nó có công điện công nghệ giữ nhiệt
khi tách này nhưng mỗi tội là nó khá lắm
cho nó thấm pháo thâm môi
Ồ không Tôi khoe này bởi vì à
đầu của Uniqlo nó có nhiều cái ấm thật
khi tôi mặc kiểu mặc đồng mỗi một cái áo
một cái quần rồi đi ra ngoài phát thêm
cái tôi nó kéo này đối với con này luôn
này quần tất này như thế này trong màu
không được đẹp và bắn Nếu ở cho mấy ông
xem bởi vì thời gian nó đồ lót bên trong
ngân hàng ra à Nhưng mà cái này ấm mấy
ông cứ thử mặc vào xem có đúng hai trăm
ba trăm nghìn thôi nhưng mà rất chậm bây
giờ kiểu mình thích có cả găng tay nữa
Mỗi đội găng tay cho nam Xấu vãi mà cả
tay tôi cũng hơn bé vào nữa hai giờ tôi
đeo găng tay cho nữ với ngón tay cho nam
thì
nó màu màu ghi
e-movie bạc Xóa Còn cam tay cho nữ lại
có màu đen Huế ra mua thế màu đen đẹp
không ạ Và cái găng tay nó có cái hay
nữa nó có
họ ngón tay người có cảm ứng được điện
thoại không ạ tự nhiên hai đầu ngón tay
của nó nó có cái ra để mà ông cảm ứng
định ông có thể vẫn đeo găng tay ông
dùng điện thoại để rất là hay
anh nói chung của tôi tôi một con người
kiểu gầy gò ốm yếu nên hãy ra là tôi
phải tôi không chịu lạnh cho chị cũng
nóng nhưng không chịu lạnh này ra là mặt
Mặc mấy cái đồ giữ nhiệt như thế mà Tôi
thấy kiểu
mặc rỡ ý thôi mà ấm Kính khùng Tôi rất
thích
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ
ok Nói chung à Mày đi ra bầu rồi như thế
còn video tiếp theo là tội chẳng nhớ lo
gì nữa cách
à à
anh vẫn nhớ video này gì đó Justin tập 9
YouTube forgot to Guess the amount for
detail with someone tell you have my
money more cửa hàng texts Justice
peppard the one special love me What to
do about the yamadas bank
youtube.com thankful that would not what
I Want Some people get to breathe
affairs of Death Note III wanna find you
play It Yourself speak yourself
draft of the best person YouTube Little
More Time passed into your laughter with
Minh lucius savings Scout
cdp When I need more to or distributing
for you
When is powered ing Women Who want to me
like you want in about you have my page
in the forests and Rush poppers She has
the news bổ sung vi chất à
à
Tôi nhớ Hình như chẳng được đấy
ừ ừ
á nhon sẵn rồi mà không ạ
Em hãy nhớ có cái tóc ở đây cơ vợ không
biết có cái tắt đấy không
à à
e-teacher
bioentry bioware ing the women Who want
me five Women want and about you have my
page in the forests and Smash our
parents have you lived
thôi mày không nghe được mà
hết à
Ừ cái cái vừa rồi Nếu mà mày ông không
biết tiếng Anh họ tôi nói tóm tắt nó như
thế này
hai đứa bé nóng và tuổi cho nó muốn tự
phát triển cái YouTube riêng bây giờ thì
như nó hơn ba trăm nghìn người theo dõi
rồi lớn hơn khá nhiều cái lời luôn à
em và nó hỏi là bí quyết cho những người
mới như nó là là nói phát triển được
mạnh như ngoài với ông mày hơn ba triệu
gì vậy bà triệu rưỡi thi ông ấy thì nó
đơn giản Đó là kiểu
thế là ông ấy kể cả lúc ông ấy 13 tuổi
28 1 tuổi như thế thì ông có người vẫn
sẽ tiếp tục làm những cái thứ mà ông ấy
cảm thấy và mục đích của ông ấy làm ngay
từ đầu
ví dụ là kiểu truyền cảm hứng Ivan như
thế chứ không nên chạy đua theo việc là
làm thế nào có thêm nhiều người theo dõi
thấy hướng của đội sẽ như thế nếu về sau
giờ xử mấy ông đã ngồi đây bây giờ đang
còn sóng đi mấy ông trả nợ sau lên sau
6.600 khâu ở đây 600.000 cho điên mất
rồi
xe Ngân Hà Nội dung cứ lên tập 600 Hồi
trước ở 600 lên được rồi bà đấy là sóng
nghìn nữa hai 60.000 còn nhìn cho cao
nhất Kiều hôm mà không khai giảng lên
với con số đấy thì
tôi vẫn sẽ nói như thế này
khi được tôi vẫn sẽ luôn à Kiểu cân nhắc
trước khi nói là chắc chắn rồi nhưng mà
tôi sẽ không biến mình hãy con người cậu
ở
ừ ừ
ý đến mình phải con người thợ giặc làm
con người khác thèm con người kiểu để
lợi nhuận để lợi ích hay là
Em hãy cố làm chiều đám đông hay gì gì
đó
về tới nhà tôi vẫn sẽ cố Chiều mấy ông ở
trong những cái khoản thôi nhưng mà ý
rồi là không biết này mọi người nấu bịch
Bố có người khác buồn toàn thì có chiều
với ông
Ừ cái mục đích của tôi ban đầu như nào
thì tôi vẫn sẽ như thế thế đợi từng nói
tôi con người hơi bị ta trưởng mà mọi
phụ làm như thế Một vì tôi có chính kiến
riêng của tôi nhiều người cùng nói
chuyện rất là tôi đã thay đổi Hẳn là như
thế luôn trừ khi là tôi cảm thấy ra cậu
nó đúng là mình sai và họ mình cần thay
đổi thôi thì mình mới thay đổi
khi con ạ à Còn việc mà kiểu có thêm nhớ
người theo dõi
à mà khiến cho mình thành con người khác
2,7 triệu phải đăng những cái đứa khác
mà mình không thích mà mình cần phải là
không đúng với mục đích ban đầu của mình
sẽ cũng vừa làm
Anh em bia điển hình kiểu thuận thiên
kiếm tiền từ mấy cái này không làm này à
à à
ờ ờ
khi tôi chia sẻ cái này không phải để
mấy miếng có thể đọc
đọc bài này sau nhé
bài thơ đó tôi không đọc tôi chỉ quan
tâm lấy ảnh thôi và Credit vn và hoa cả
Korra pm miệng cũng theo dõi để 2-pass
về hai diện đàn một diễn đàn để hỏi đáp
Cùng diễn đàn kiểu là để mạng Mọi người
lên đấy
trao đổi với tất cả mọi thứ nó rất nhiều
kênh có kênh kiệu từ cây liệu rất là
đáng yêu cho anh canh rất là hay cho đến
tinh hiểu rất là 18 cộng gần có hết thế
này bởi vì nó diễn đàn và nó cái
mọi thứ thông tin của nó đều mở thành ra
là cậu
đăng bất kỳ cái gì từ từ bậy bạ nhạy cảm
nhất kinh dị nhất cho đến hài hước kiểu
đáng yêu chưa này có hết Ừ thế này là
trên đây đúng phù hợp cho ông nào cũng
phải chọn lọc thông tin được không thì
ông ấy sẽ bị thứ nhất là có tải không
tin thứ hai sẽ bị nhiều cái cậu bị sao
nhãng bởi vì những cái kênh băng thông
tin bổ ích có rất nhiều nhưng mà nếu
không chọn lọc mình nếu không xảy ra
được đọc được Toàn giác nóng ạ
Nên đại ca ở đây có cái ảnh này
ờ ờ
em làm việc từ 9 giờ sáng chắc thế nên
Tâm đã không lại nói chỗ nào 9 tiếng mỗi
ngày chứ cứ cho từ 8 giờ sáng ấy đã mơ
sáng đến 12 giờ 4 tiếng này thì 5 tiếng
buổi chiều nữa cho các từ 1 giờ đến 6
giờ đi đấy à
36 Giờ Sau đó thì còn năm tiền trước khi
ngủ là 11 giờ đi ngủ Ừ cứ cho là thế
à Mà ông Khi mà bị hỏi như thế này thậm
chí là đối với lập trình viên tôi từng
nó là thời gian thoải mái Điền hình
giống như mấy ông đã thấy tôi từng nói
rồi tôi Ngày nào cũng thể ngồi chém gió
mấy ông được vào buổi tối rồi nha mấy
ông Nghĩa nói chuyện viên của kiếm được
lương cao rảnh Rảnh vãi chưa xong rồi
Thỉnh thoảng thì anh đấy nửa đêm vẫn còn
ngồi chơi dâu ta ở sáng ngày hôm sau bảo
nó dậy sáng dậy họp xong rồi lại ngủ cái
thứ thật chị viên sướng toàn tại nhà như
lương vẫn nghìn đô nhưng sướng rồi Đúng
không Hồng Hồng vào
tới việc sướng ấy thì nhất à mẹ mấy ông
phải xác định được là công nghiệp mà mày
uống trọ
vì nó có ưu ưu và nhược như thế nào và
mấy ông thích để lưu lại không mà chịu
được cái ngược Đấy không
cho nó giống hệt tôi thường hay so sánh
cái việc tình yêu này nó rất giống hệt
với cái mối quan hệ của mấy ông tập chữa
mối quan hệ lấy giống kiểu vợ chồng ấy
đó là
Ừ ông sẽ tốn gần như ngày nào cũng thế
cho nó và vào nó có thể kéo dài rất lâu
thậm chí cả đồi
cho sự nghiệp mà không ạ
Nên là mấy ông
Ê mấy ông sẽ phải cân nhắc trước thì
chọn gì đó thậm chí phải thay đổi một
vài cái cho trước khi chọn đồng cái gì
đó lâu dài như thế
và tôi Không coi đấy là công việc vợ
từng nói rồi giống như vừa Tôi so sánh
với nhiều thế thôi có người yêu thì cá à
Nhiều người nghĩ màu hồng Thôi để tôi
nói là người yêu không phải là một màu
hồng nhiêu là muôn màu nó sẽ có đủ màu
đen một tối màu xám ấy rồi ông ấy ông
công việc cũng thế họ sẽ có đủ màu như
thế công công việc nó sẽ có lúc vui và
chắc chắn nó sẽ có lúc rất mệt chồng
ngoại
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà suy nghĩ kiểu như tôi
vừa nghĩ đến mấy ông sẽ không có để công
việc nữa mấy ông sẽ coi Đấy là kiểu mình
làm như một thói quen làm hàng ngày làm
cậu trách nhiệm của mình giống như
chuyện tình cảm thôi mình đã chọn nó cứ
làm hết sức mình nó hồi trước tôi đi làm
mấy ông rẽ mấy ông mấy ông có nhớ vụ ở
tôi nói cái năm nhất của tôi tôi đi làm
ở quán bar hoặc tôi đi làm khoản Ba tôi
làm ở siêu thị tôi làm Ờ tôi làm từ bồi
bàn cho đề nữa pha chế cho đến cả chúng
Sẽ có
mấy ông sẽ nghĩ là tôi không phù hợp
công việc đúng tôi từng nghĩ thế
Anh Hello mấy ông sẽ nghĩ là tôi sẽ bỏ
việc sớm không tôi không bỏ việc mà ông
sẽ nghĩ rằng là tôi à
ờ ờ kiểu dạng mà lạnh đến làm trong sự
chán à áp lực và không thoải mái không
tôi không như thế
em thậm chí cá hồi mà tội làm bồi bàn
rồi đấy tôi rồi
Anh nghịch làm bồi bàn thì các là mấy
ông không sếp của mấy ông sẽ bảo là
làm 8 tiếng mỗi ngày và xếp mấy ông rất
khá sẽ khá khó chịu khi mà mày Ông ngồi
nhiều Nếu nghĩ ra ông ạ Ông Bùi bạn cũng
ngồi bàn khách họ đã Cứ ngồi ở chỗ thu
ngân
em gà luôn khách thì luôn muốn nhìn thấy
một ông cậu luôn Đúng kiểu phục vụ mình
thì hợp lý hơn đúng không thấy cái thế
nên bỏ tôi có chỗ ngồi ở bên trong phòng
ở trong Sau Thu Ngân
và sẽ phải ở cửa mỗi thỉnh thoảng Nếu mà
không có khách hay không việc gì thì thể
vào đấy ngồi thay vì ngồi ngoài tôi
không bao giờ một trong vòng 8 tiếng ủi
tôi đảm rồi đấy hai tháng hay là trước
khi là tôi bị à
Ừ bia bệnh thiếu máu do hợp với thế giới
thì làm căng quá tốt bị thiếu máu vì
giảm căng cơ thiếu máu và tim Huế Đi
khám tìm được tim đập quá nhanh thiếu
máu cục bộ vì cậu bị lâu lâu không không
lao động cả không không nợ không lao
động không vận động chân tay rồi Hồi nãy
đi làm thì cảm với anh đấy Tôi không
không nghỉ ngơi luôn trong đúng làn
riêng đấy thôi cứ nghĩ là phải làm tôi
không dừng không có không không không có
khái niệm rồi cậu nghịch chơi điện thoại
không ngồi luôn cơ mà nó sẽ làm việc
liên tục như thế cho dù đấy không phải
con huyện công việc mà tôi muốn xong rồi
Tôi làm nhờ một khi tôi làm gì
tôi sẽ không nghĩ đấy là làm
Ừ bác sĩ thứ nhất ở Tôi nghĩ à mình đặt
mình thằng khách hàng khi mình muốn đến
quá mình sẽ kẹo thấy một ông nhân viên
Như nào thứ hai là mình đặt mình và ông
chủ thì mà thôi Một Hoàng nhân viên thì
thằng đấy vải như thế nào
vợ
chồng hai hàng ấy cho ra Hà Nội
làm đến đâu vậy ra tôi không khuyên về
ông như thế những tình tôi nói thế thì
tôi ở một khi làm thì sẽ à
em làm
ra khổng vợ già nhô ra khỏi Bởi vì không
ai ép được tôi làm cái gì Thôi ghét tôi
sẽ làm cái gì mà tôi tự nguyện tới làm
và vì tự nguyện nên Hay là mình rất là
thoải mái
có nhiều người ở đây vì hoàn cảnh nên mà
phải chọn công việc mà họ không thích
nhưng mà Chính vì thế họ lại làm theo
kiểu một cách miễn cưỡng đối phó 2 giờ
cậu Tại sao mình gọi sống của sống đối
phó đúng ạ chiến đó mình bị mệt hơn các
thứ thứ biết là có rất nhiều người do
hoàn cảnh mình không thể
Ừ
quan điểm mình tất cả được Nhưng mà nếu
có thể nếu có thể nếu không sẽ chọn
những cái phù hợp hơn mình và sẽ làm tin
là làm được Kiểu tốt hơn không ạ
à à
a và và hi vọng là kiểu các bạn về sau
đều chọn được công việc nào nó phù hợp
mình không không phải theo mỗi ngày công
nghệ tin này không phải cho mỗi ngày lập
trình thì bây giờ ngành công nghệ tin và
rất nhiều luôn rất nhiều Hôm trước chị
mình vừa còn vừa nhắn nói mình chế hồi
trước và làm thứ hai là mở Tuyết Tân nữa
cả đúng hỏi thường ai làm thế thân thôi
tự tự nhiên cả không trước bảo là
em biết về về cái mảng này không xong
rồi hỏi mình về mấy cái của Microsoft
với bạn là bây giờ sẽ đăng ký về thời
làm mai có giúp em cái xịn đấy nhớ đời
ta là thế bảo là từ cao cũng làm vỡ giao
tiếp kiểu hỗ trợ support bên marketing
thôi Nhưng mà ở lại liên quan đến công
nghệ pin thì thế nên là mình thấy à Là
bây giờ cái gì cũng có không phải ông
tin rồi từ một người tiếp toàn Hồi trước
thì nói chuyện với người với người không
biết lý công nghệ thông tin thì không
cần động máy tính cũng được thì bây giờ
cũng phải ngồi học hỏi Anh để máy phù
hợp hơn 10 cái 10 cái cậu xu thế bây giờ
rồi
tôi thấy em bây giờ mới ông phải thay
đổi phải phải kiểu phải cậu chạy theo
công nghệ thông tin và kiếm một nghề gì
ông nổi nóng ạ
ở hồ Sen nốt ngày nay trước khi vào buổi
hôm nay tâm sự hơi nhiều rồi nốt nốt nốt
một cái đúng à
Xin chào Cái này cái hay đấy
Tik Tok
anh
chưa có ăn gì
cho nó thì
cũng soạn rồi à
[âm nhạc]
khi
cây giờ tôi muốn chia sẻ với ông Nếu là
nó Hài thứ hai là
không phải cho mấy ông ăn cơm chó đâu
gì mà lạ ở ở
Ừ nếu em thấy vừa rồi Thế còn một cái
video nữa cơ Thôi lại phải chia sẻ được
cái áo nữa à
à à
anh không nói về con gái chủ động trong
trường hợp này nữa mà nói việc và à
Ê mấy ông cứ thoại thoải mái thấy giờ
giả ngoài tự nhiên trong mối quan hệ đôi
khi ở cậu sẽ có những gì đó cậu ập đến
à à
Ừ nhưng mà tôi không nói được trong
trường hợp này xấu hay tốt nha biết đâu
Kiểu Nếu mà tiêu cực nhất của mấy Maurer
Thằng ấy nói biết đâu đổ bỏ tìm con cái
chủ động như thế
em không nói gì sớm thôi nói cho bộ hôm
nay sẽ
thì tôi à
em lấy hết cốt mới của các nhóm về với
tôi trận nữa nhé ạ
Anh ở cốt nhiều mệt nhanh lao động chân
tay ở khá đau não mà đúng ạ
A và
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
ý là Cái quan trọng là thì cốc thì nó sẽ
cậu gọi nhé
cho
cô thì
khi mà các bạn bị đau não Ý thời gian
hồi phục các bạn lâu hơn so với giờ các
bạn hiểu mọi cơ Cái gì đó anh thế
à à
Ừ dạo này anh bị khó ngủ do đầu cứ nghĩ
mày cái cốt con gió à
từ trước anh có bị như vậy không
ờ ờ thứ nhất là mình không ngủ thường
anh không ngủ lúc 12 giờ đâu
an ninh toàn Ngủ dậy chỉ cần muộn hơn và
Ừ Ừ
mình thường anh nghĩ về cốt nghỉ liên
tục gì cả nghĩ cả từ lúc mà kia đang tắm
thì nghĩ là đi đường mình nghĩ này
em làm việc khá bị thỉnh thoảng nghĩ đến
Cốt
em đứng yên làm thế thì mơ mình nghĩ rồi
mơ mình nhớ nó nghỉ mất dạy cô mình cậu
Nghĩa cách sửa cốt bị mất dạy cơ
Em có phải thay đổi
Ừ đợi thì giải thích file này thay đổi
cả
à à
Ê BB tôn này là tôi đăng ký bằng tài
khoản à Cái đù này nó miễn phí
anh có nghiện chẳng Cũng đúng không nhận
nhiều thứ lắm Tôi là con Na con sâu mà
Ừ ok
Xuka Có vài nhóm Đợi mình tí nhé mình mở
có một vài nhỏ vừa nhắn tin cho mình thì
như có linh mới vậy
anh nói Thôi mình cứ tạm trăm những cái
nhóm đang có hiện tại đây lại nhá Ừ
bạn này chính cái chưa kéo về ạ ạ
à à
ở trên này Hôm trước mình xem quạ nhóm
Hôm trước đã Chuẩn đấy
thứ hai nó 1 Ừ đúng một cả nhóm 2 ngày
mai không kéo được cái bìa I find
em đang có phải có mít lên xe hơi lạ
Ừ kệ độ lại như cố đây ạ
ừ ừ
à à
à à Vì sao phải lại thế nhóm này vẫn
tách làm hai đậu xanh
Ừ
lúc nào tôi nghĩ về người yêu tôi á Ờ
thì ca tôi Tôi từng nói ông ra tôi hơi
bị vô tâm tí tao cái khoản là không phải
không nghĩ người yêu mà là
ừ ừ
thiết kế hồi mà tôi dụng hồi Đắng không
phải Hồi đang tán nữa Nói chung là hồi
ngoài kiểu không được ở bên nhau ấy Ừ
thì ah tôi à
Ê tôi hay nghĩ bằng yêu tôi chẳng làm
được cái gì cả kể cả Cốt
anh nhiều lắm Tôi bị thế đúng mùa khi mà
kẹo khi ở với nhau đấy
tử vi tính tôi được họ nhận
tôi thấy là bình an kiểu kiểu dạng mà
thoải mái vui vẻ và làm được tất cả
những việc khác nhưng tay ga kiểu truyền
hình nền hình nhé
bây giờ hàng ngày tôi tôi sẽ ngồi làm
việc như lại thật chứa tôi đã ngồi nói
chuyện với ông như này và bạn đấy ngồi
bên cạnh bạn làm bất kỳ cái gì được Tại
bạn ngồi chơi game Bạn làm gì đó ngồi
làm việc bên cạnh tôi cảm thấy rất là
thoải mái nhà kiểu an tâm kiểu nhẹ nhõm
trong lòng sẽ thấy không hiểu vì sao chả
thích có người ở bên kia cái hết Tôi chỉ
thích kiểu thế thôi không không mức ra
là tôi nghĩa về các bạn thì nó Ừ nó cũng
tương đối ổn ở điểm là kiểu ông không để
ông không cả ngày quấn người yêu thương
giữa cả ngày không có làm được gì đấy
Không phải có người chở hàng có người
chọn hàng nào hoàn toàn thì cậu
còn những cuộc sống riêng của họ Nhưng
mà họ vẫn kiểu chia sẻ với nhau những
cái kiểu
nhiều cái có thể chia sẻ được ăn cùng
nhau hay làm việc làm được những thứ
khác cùng nhau được một cái cùng nhau
thì vẫn vui nhưng mà còn khi mà những
lúc khác đấy thì ông tập trung vào được
công việc của ông tập trung vào cuộc
sống riêng của ông được Thì đấy là có
người tôi cảm thấy thế là ổn mẹ con
người trưởng thành sẽ không phải là kiểu
mấy ông bây giờ mà ông đã bị khí hôn
linh cảm nên là méo nó họ nghĩ chuyện
yêu đương tội từng bị thế mà tôi không
làm được gì cả hơi sai ừ ừ
ở nhóm 1 ok
anh đem bị dễ mua sen tốt nhé
a Vietnamese đi
à à
thật
sự có bảng
nhân viên đi nhân viên của các bạn nhé
họa sản phẩm
các tế bào tôi sẽ chấm ngẫu nhiên đi nhé
áo
đội tuyển đi đấy à
ở thẻ thư viện ông ạ
Em bấm vào đây nhanh được đấy
liên kết thư viện đây là khi sex
cho tôi bảo mày ôm không chơi một Đông
nơi ông cứ chén hay một Đống thư viện về
ok
Ừ cái gì đấy à
Em phải nhớ Sai
anh bấm mà không được này
anh chấm chấm Yoga chấm chấm Soda
ở súp gà socola xe đap đấy
cơ sở thật trong các hoành tráng ok
Ê sexsy phóng sản phẩm
Sao mẹ không nói bản à không nối với thể
loại
anh có thể loại này nó không nói thể
loại thì lấy tên thể loại rồi đi à Lại
thêm câu truy vấn nữa như này quả này
lên cho hợp lý hơn do lấy tên của thể
loại nó hợp lý hơn
ẩm thực kiểu như này thì có bao nhiêu
cầu sản phẩm hiển thị đã bấy nhiêu đã
làm như này thiếu và Phương tranh này
chiếu vào tìm kiếm trên trang này không
ạ nhưng chắc là mình chưa yêu cầu các
bạn đấy Chả buổi sau mình sẽ bổ sung với
vụ này lại đi luôn
À thỉnh thoảng mình mới nhớ ra cái gì Do
mình phải bổ sung
ờ ờ ờ
à à
tổ chức năng à
ở trên xe ở đây này
vào đây này à ạ Và bây giờ sẽ ra tìm
kiếm và Phương tranh này
nó tạm thời Thế à
ờ ờ
Ừ chứ mày ông ấy như này thì có bao
nhiêu sản phẩm nghĩa bấy nhiêu anh chẳng
qua bài Ý sản phẩm nó không bị thế thôi
oneclick kiểm tra lại xác thực xóa trong
các loại ổi tim heo thử một cái file nữa
nhé thì một file
thêm để thêm form thêm xem sản phẩm mới
Golden 49 phút tận hai cái này luôn à
chú ý là tất cả
Ừ ok
chồng mẹ ôm
thêm có xét cái này thì da mình từng
khuyên các bạn về cách đặt tên rồi bởi
vì thêm là thêm này trong trường hợp với
nó rằng sau này Nhưng mà thêm là lên
đằng trước này bạn sẽ dễ bị ở mình
khuyên là các bạn có thể đi thêm nên là
trước cũng được để cho nó kiểu
có phải là cạnh cạnh nhau ấy mà cả nó có
tí thống nhất Nội việc là một đằng sau
hết hai lần trước hết năm trước hết thì
mình nghĩ hợp lý hơn để kiểu họ sẽ xếp
ngay hay phải ở cạnh nhau tìm một dễ
anh em tên câu Insert đơn giản thôi Cái
này được các bạn quên thiếu kiểm tra xem
à là là nó có lỗi gì không
Ông Hà ông ấy có điều hướng quay lại mà
không cho thế à đến bấm với lại
anh như thế Bây giờ cha ngài sẽ
chị sẽ một trang trắng tinh có mỗi thẻ
thì bấm cái loại trải nghiệm người dùng
trong trường hợp này mình thấy thử cao
không tốt lắm Nhưng mà thực ra là
bắt đầu tuần sau mình sẽ dạy các bạn về
việc à
chị xem thêm sữa xóa bằng á
đ.g.đ kết hợp với Isaac họ sẽ là kiểu
không cần quá lạnh trang thì không cần
lại điều hướng nữa trải nghiệm người
dùng sẽ tội rất là ổn hơn của nó khá
nhiều cứ bấm thành công bấm cái form sẽ
được đẩy đi
nhưng mà cha không tải lại không nhảy đi
đâu cả bạn nó sẽ trả về thông báo thành
công ấy thất bại thôi Alo ạ
Ừ ok
đi Thấy cũng tương đối được rồi anh mình
chị kiểm tra một ngoài pha ngẫu nhiên mà
Ừ ok tiếp theo là nhóm số 2
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu méo nhỉ kỹ thì ở cái cái cái công
cụ ý this tool box của tôi
à à
sự hiện hiện đăng nhập thay vì Hiển thị
một đống phá thì các bạn tạo file đầu
tiên là bạn phải tạo file Excel ppt và
không thì đóng vai hay đấy Lại còn lên
là phải form đăng nhập luôn
à à
Anh không nghỉ à phải đấy các bạn thì
phải Trang trụ được nhưng mà phải có
thêm kiểm tra quyền Nếu mà season chưa
có chứa đăng nhập nóng lạnh thì các bạn
điều hướng người phòng đăng nhập
Anh tên admin Android xem
cho mấy chị có thêm rồi nhìn lại mới
chịu thêm đúng không ạ
ở vai trò luôn
là số năm công tác có ngoài live thời
gian nào Ừ tự nhiên thừa khoảng trắng
đấy
anh
Giang đô nam nữ
à à
anh
hả gì vậy
à à thời gian vào à ở
thời gian Nam hiện tại - 5 Đà sẽ ra số
năm công tác đi phết nhỉ Không hẳn đúng
lắm nếu muốn chuẩn theo cả ngày nhưng mà
cũng được
anh quản lí nhân viên
đóng kết nối ok
mà tại sao lại đóng ở đây nhỉ
ở ngoài để đóng cho màu làm à à không
em ở đâu nhỉ
tiross post ở đây
khi tôi đóng chai ở Nguyệt đóng chai rồi
sai rồi chồng tôi ở ngoài này sao rồi
Ô thế không mày Ông mày không để ý kĩ
nhá phố ích này không ạ Mở tr này đóng
đô ở ngoài
ô hay sai rồi sai rồi sai rồi
anh ngắm hai nhóm tôi chỉ cần đọc code
của mấy ông ơi nhá Nhung phần cốt Đồn
một thì vẫn đang nhắn nếu mà có đồ ăn
hay thì đó cũng tách nhiều file này ra
vẫn có thể kiểm tra cậu lại được
Ê bà cái may quy iCloud các bạn hãy đóng
sớm cũng được ngay sau vài câu truy vấn
này Perry xong các bạn đóng luôn được
các bạn chạy phuacs các thử thoải mái
không sao cả không ảnh hưởng gì cả vì dữ
liệu lấy ra rồi ở nhà không bị ảnh hưởng
nữa
Ừ mình đang thứ nhất ở các bạn để ý nhá
các bạn thì chị chan bên cạnh này không
ạ Cái chữ tre bên cạnh mình đang cài cái
tiện cài Pocket của thằng mai thằng Hình
như thằng vs cốt có rất nhiều từ Pocket
mình sẽ mình không dùng nó không biết
được ít toolbox này thực chất là nó
nhưng các bạn thấy là mình có thể ấn
phím tắt nhanh để mà kéo toàn bộ cốt mới
về
Ừ thứ hai là nó thì chị ra lịch sử mình
mình thử phím tắt cho mày ông xem lịch
sự nhé
a.how đấy Nó sẽ hiển thị lịch sử những
cái đoạn mà mình đang bôi đang bôi à
em
xem lịch sử kiểu Ai đã cốt dòng này thực
sự dòng này như thế nào gần cuối kiểu
sát được các thứ thứ như nào hoặc cả chị
và Chính đây thì hiển thị tên của người
đã cốt tại dòng này luôn này rất là hay
đúng không ạ
Ê bà thêm một cái nữa là
thằng nó lại ít nên hoàn toàn là nó sẽ
có gợi ý các từ thứ như này không ạ
khi mình cài thêm cái nữa của anh Tuấn
khuyên mình cái xem kẻ yêu này là cái
cái này nó là cậu gợi ý thêm một cái quy
chuẩn thêm nữa và nó còn gợi ý nhiều cái
kiểu đoạn này Thưa đoạn này thiếu cái gì
đó biến này có thể không tồn tại vừa nãy
ông có xem nếu người ông để ý kĩ đây
trong trường hợp này biến này không tồn
tại này ngây thơ Cái này nó đọc nó hơi
bị sai thỉnh thoảng nó đọc hơi sai đúng
vì lỡ dành cho file này có biển này có
tồn tại rồi nhưng mà nó đây Thực ra sẽ
hơi say nhau bởi vì nó không tìm thấy
trong cả cái file này không phải khai
báo biến này nó nó nó báo được thế rồi
nhưng mà nhiều lúc như thế nó sẽ ổn ví
dụ trong trường hợp này nó bảo là dùng
bao giờ ba ngày nó chặt chẽ hơn nữa nạn
giữa ô tô
Ừ
ông kêu vừa So sánh pass tôm và vs code
đúng không ạ
à à ở đây Nói chung nhà Đấy cũng là một
trong lý do mà mình mình đang
mình thấy là cái buổi chấm như này nó
không hề thừa Mình chỉ ở các bạn rất
nhiều cái mẹo của mình nữa nhiều cái hay
nữa Nó không phải là cốt nhưng mà
ý nghĩa là kiểu hôm nay không dạy kiến
thức về cốt cho mình dạy kiến thức kiểu
về có thể mình nặng chấm như thế nào này
các bạn nên nhìn là những nhóm khác nên
sửa những cái gì này ngoan và những cái
tôn mình dùng để hỗ trợ cho mình như thế
nào với Vân hoặc thậm chí đoạn này nên
tối ưu như thế nào sửa đoạn này ra ăn
Nếu mà bạn nào mà kiểu quen dần rồi thì
các bạn biết được là TP nó sẽ có cái trò
là gan nhiều ngôn ngữ khác này nói cho
lại các bạn sẽ thường có thể ghi nó điều
kiện để con đi xin
sau đó thì họ chấm dứt Khi mà đúng và
Khi say thì sẽ như thế nào và sự nhé
trong trường hợp này thì các bạn kiểm
tra giới tính đúng không ạ thì trên đâu
rồi ạ rồi render
bằng bằng không thì nếu mà đúng thì mình
sẽ in ra là phụ nữ cảnh nhạn còn sai
mình sẽ đi là nam như các ạ Và mình chị
trên Metro năm trước nghe được và thường
là mình thường ấy Mình thích cái kiểu đó
là mình sẽ cho đây mặc tròn như thế này
mình thích thế Mình thích trễ
nhìn cho rõ lại
Ừ đúng rồi Cái kiểu này để nít em nhanh
ngay trên cùng một dòng ấy thỉnh thoảng
tôi lại chị ông thêm một vài cái như thế
này có vai ông chỉ thấy cái này quá hiển
nhiên rồi vì mọi ngôn ngữ lập trình khác
nó đều có cái điều này mọi ngôn ngữ lập
trình khác đều có
khi
nãy đấy ông kia nghĩa là mỗi ra Speed có
thấy đúng không nó xếp lên nhau sẽ có
một vài toán tử nó cũng khá là dị khác
nhưng mà pp là bây giờ nó TP mới dồi
trên 7 cái cái cái này già nó ở cũ có
rồi nhá như làn T7 T8 bây giờ nó còn
thêm nhiều cái nữa
Ok nói chung với ông này tôi bảo ơi Góp
ý về vụ đây rồi đúng không sợ lại không
Này trang nhà bạn nữ này tôi đôi khi gọi
con trai là con trai con gái đưa ông này
ông 13 hết
trò chơi cả bằng tuổi hay nhỏ tuổi hơn
hay lớn tuổi hơn nữa vợ ông bà hay
đấy Thực ra chính để cách cách gọi của
tôi thế nó tránh bị nhàm chán
a và và
vì nó sẽ khiến cho mọi người Cảm thấy
kiểu mình đang nói chuyện với họ một
cách rất là thoải mái tự nhiên em cách
tán gái Mày mày Ông cứ nhắn tin được con
gái mà mày Ông bảo cứ xưng hô ông với
tôi thay vì suy ngẫm Hòa xương màu bạc
được đấy tôi Bà hãy gì đó thay vì cậu tớ
này ạ Hay là bạn mình nè em ạ Em em anh
hay gì đó tôi về ông Hai cứ cũng được
đấy thử xem
dự án nhưng mà à
cho tôi bảo rồi vẫn là tùy ấy nhé bởi vì
à Vẫn phụ thuộc nhiều yếu tố ná
Anh hiểu nữa anh sẽ bảo ông bố duyên đấy
nhưng mà
anh nói được à Nếu mà giờ sự mà ông tán
bạn đấy mà bảo ông vô duyên ý chứ Hai
người không hợp nhau hãy
a manufacturer Ok cũng được Hay ở đâu để
tôi xem cái nào order rồi có gì rồi hả
mỗi đấy à
I love you
Anh đang update đi xem
Ừ ông này à không có hết đâu à trẻ lạ
hơn nhiều nhỉ
khi tỉa vẫn trẻ lại Đồng Nai nhưng về cơ
bản đoạn này vẫn bị lặp lại đúng không ạ
Các bạn nên tống hết toàn bộ cái này vào
một file header của bên chút sau đó chỉ
đốt nó hợp lý hơn sẽ hơi nhiều
ở với ông ấy chạy lại cảm ấy mua rồi
ở trận cảm ăn menu à
em hãy về sau nếu mà thay đổi cái gì đó
là thai có thể thay đổi rất nhiều file
mai ở đồn hai mà em không bị dính vào
trường hợp này nữa nhưng đón một thì các
bạn cũng phải quen dần rồi ghi vào thời
sự lại đúng ngay không ạ Và tôi bảo ơi
Không nên để ở anh được Việt ở đây không
ạ đó post lên dịch ra là gì quản lý à
trang chủ đấy Trang chụp sẽ hội
anh phải đi
Ừ ok ở đây hiển thị mỗi em Còn hiển thị
gì nữa
anh không biết luôn
à kêu 13 đi đêm nhạc giấc mới
về giá số lượng
Ê bà yên trong dip cho cũng thật là tôi
đừng khuyên mày ông hôm trước cũng nói
vụ này rồi Nếu mà bên trang quản lý được
cả người ta không cần anh thì cách mồm
mẹ lắm trừ khi nó ít thì các bạn ấy hiển
thị trong dip Còn không thì nên định
trong Thay bồ lại người ta và cái quan
trọng ấy thì hôm trước có nói bởi vì à
nếu mà các bạn hình bị trong từng cái
đít kiểu ba cái đít bên cạnh nhau ấy
tôi thử bạn này xem vào được xem thẳng
luôn cho chủ quan nhé
à à
I am in a
ừ ừ
khi nào được rồi nó nghỉ à
ở
Đắk hưởng ở
anh ạ
kỹ
thuật status cái kiểm tra đăng nhập được
à à
anh bày thịt bởi vì bạn ấy hiển thị ra
như thế này khi bấm vào sửa xóa thứ nhà
đọc đứt là giờ khó nữa bấm sửa xóa dễ bị
bấm nhầm ở việc nó không thẳng một cột
Nếu có hiểu không Cái thì mày mấy ông
phải sửa lại vụ này
Ở đây có là sản phẩm nữa sản phẩm về sau
sẽ rất nhiều màn hiển thị ra lại giữ bị
tràn Nếu muốn chưa làm tình tính năng
kiểu tìm kiếm một phương trang nữa sẽ
thật nó đoạn này kiểu về sau dài dằng
dặc nữa còn chết nữa
em nghe máy ông lên để này xong thấy bồ
hợp lý hơn
à à
anh hả
Ừ ông kêu Đăng khuyên chửi nhau con gà
ở bên nhau em gái phở
356 sánh được
Ừ để thử Atlat đi
à à
anh hả
khi Cốc Cốc đúng không Tại sao update
Gold bạn ấy chạy nhà rồi
Nếu mà có cốt kiểu nhà Nếu mà tôi lưỡi
tôi sẽ có cho khác thể làm cho này đấy ạ
em kiểm tra nếu không tồn tại thì mình
sẽ
anh kể truyền vào một đập 4 tên của tên
của cô đặt nó tại
truyền kể tên file vào được
Em làm chỗ nào chuyển thể biển phố Đắc
vào sông forex thì nó sẽ hiểu là sản
phẩm xông pha treo ở sẽ là định nhà suốt
sao nói sau đó thì thay 2 đuôi vào đấy ạ
là thay cái biến nó vào đây là được
vợ
chồng lại cứ buồn cười
khi mẹ mất đến lại ba hết hả ổn Đấy mẹ
định ra biết các kỹ đấy ông ạ
à à
có cách nào tắc bị tách ra
em đón hay thì các bạn sẽ học được cách
nha không hẳn cách tách đâu mà bản chất
là đồ ăn hay thì các bạn sẽ dùng cái
template của nó thì nói đúng mà
10 kiểu dáng sẽ có vậy sẽ có phải nói 5p
thôi không không để tránh được Giả sử
giống như vừa rồi để kiểm tra ở kiểu Nếu
mà season vẫn có tồn tại thì I nào ra
chữ nếu mà bạn dùng lạm dụng ra clip để
mà in in mọi thứ ra là nó không tốt
hả ông này
cho iOS ngon
anh lại ra này Ok này thêm nhà sản xuất
mới
đấy đấy bởi vì mình không có cốt vì có
cốt nhưng có dẫn cốt ở dưới ở dài và rất
nhiều chỗ này sửa thành ra là cậu mấy
ông thầy ông mấy ông quên sửa là có ngờ
trong nói như thế này này
Ừ đấy tội bắt đầu tuần sau mình dậy JJ
răng nha
à à
Anh không nghĩ tên file được ra về sau
các bạn không cần phải nghĩ nhiều ở trên
file đâu các bạn có một quy chuẩn là tên
file là chỗ ngồi đón hay các bạn sẽ thấy
toàn bộ những cái câu hỏi mà các bạn hỏi
bây giờ thận chứa các bạn cũng hỏi luôn
nóng Giải đáp toàn khá nhiều vì nó theo
một cái mô hình vừa thêm Phương muốn vào
đó
về sau mình dậy mình mình đồ ăn một Nói
chung là nó đang rất là nông dân phải di
ảnh người nông dân mới thủ công là công
thủ công này toàn bộ những sơ sài Vân
Vân này tôi rồi đến hai mình nói rồi nó
như cậu một cái gì đó rất là kinh khủng
nó bị rượu khác rất nhiều và khiến cho
khi mà các bạn học đồ ăn hay thì mình
cảm thấy sướng hơn rất nhiều Mình cảm
thấy một chân trời mới các thứ mình yêu
mình yêu lập trình sau khi học xong cái
cái mô hình các tự thưởng để mình cảm
thấy tự nhiên mình thấy thông minh hơn
đấy Hiểu cơ thể
à à
Ừ nhưng mà đấy là xem thực sự mấy ông
thích một vài cái của lập trình không đã
hiểu rằng mà
chị và mấy ông kiểu dạng là gọi nhà nghỉ
để ông chịu Được không ạ
mã sản phẩm đi sai Lại
Tôi đi kì cục đây
số lượng này tự nhiên chỗ đấy không biết
hoa này
Ê mấy ông nên lên nhớ nha nếu mày không
theo quy tắc viết hoa thì chữ cái đầu
mày không phải luôn kế hoạch chợ Cái đầu
nếu muốn viết hoa hay kiểu dạng mà kiểu
tiêu đề viết hoa tất cả chữ cái đầu
thích mấy ông vẫn phải làm thế giới đầu
năm cuối Đừng có kiểu nửa nạc nửa mỡ gặp
ngay không chuyên nghiệp cực luôn ấy nói
chung miếng phải tìm ý vào tính tôi tìm
nghị lực
bạn hãy dùng Br2 lại nhé chỗ này Bây giờ
cả những ai không để cốt không biết có
phòng rồi
Ừ cái kiểu Br này tôi thấy quen cực khó
khi vợ cút bằng à Hồi đấy thôi làm bằng
dreamweaver
dùng à Control Center nó sẽ ra cái nó sẽ
ra cái PR cũ cũ này
vì bản quyền của vệ Ok bạn
Butter không để con phải riêng cái thật
Ừ Ông này ông ạ đi tiểu
Ê mấy ông ở tự biết bản thân mình rồi
không ạ sử anh ạ
Ừ nhưng mà công nhận nhóm này đã làm cái
đấy cái thời thứ vẻ ổn chết rồi
ô kê
đoạn này sai này làm này chắc làm sai
đấy bạn này cho và bếp này nghĩ như này
có phải ổn nhân thực là không Bởi vì
đoạn này nó sẽ bảo lỗi luôn khi mà không
tìm thấy bất kì cái này rồi chứ Vậy đến
đây đương nhiên là
đương nhiên là kiểu gì nó sẽ tờ quay lại
nói mãi không thấy nhưng mà đoạn này nó
đã bảo lỗi khi một thông tin mới này rồi
nên bạn phải kiểm tra cái này trước khi
kiểm tra cái này trước khi khai báo như
này đâu ạ ạ
v-app Days
bạn kok vẻ ổn rồi bà anh Dũng Xuân để
máy hiển thị lại gọi là lần trước tôi
bảo ấy nó ra flash để màn hiển thị ra
cái đồ vẫn sử
ừ ừ
nhà
máy bia rất là nhiều or local Tôi từng
nói cái lấy từ lần trước rồi mai phải ăn
nhiều hơn Microsoft
oracle là Microsoft Word nhở đúng không
Mình nhớ thế bởi vì cái đấy mất phí mà
a vlxx công ty dùng cũng nhờ ít lập
trình viên học đấy hơn Sao Mai với lắm
Ừ
ok ở chỗ mà
ở nhóm này vẫn có vẻ ôm
Nghe có vẻ ổn thôi ạ tuần này tôi là tôi
bảo kiểm tra vest nhưng mà hình như cũng
nhóm mua rồi còn chưa VAT nữa thôi
tạm bỏ qua đã
Ừ tôi cứ đang dư dả thời gian vẫn đang
thoải mái mấy ông ấy đến hôm gần gần đến
bảo vệ rồi tôi sẽ kiểm tra một loạt xe
mình nhóm ấy thực sự đã làm
đầy đủ các thử đúng yêu cầu chưa Đấy
mắng chửi rau câu em mắng chửi xong mấy
ông cũng không dám bỏ để tôi mắng xong
mày không bỏ tôi buồn lắm
khi
bạn lặp lại cái từ mai mình hơi nhiều và
không cân học được Cũng được về tách
riêng hẳn là
xe mà nhóm 5 thiếu
em biết hôm này thiếu gì
Cho tôi xem nhé
I can't read
Cô Đơn giản thôi từ cái đơn giản nữa bạn
này không phải ếch nhà file này Nếu rảnh
đấy thì hợp lý hơn
à à
Ừ đạo hàm để con ếch à Cũng được nhỉ
có tổng số item hiển thị ra tổng số
em có tiền
à à
a lô a lô hiển thị gia tổng số lại dùng
bdo ô
a
= 200
à à code lại thông báo theo kiểu là trở
về đúng hoặc sai
xin lỗi server 20
Ừ đúng rồi mai đây Phải làm từ cả hai
bên
à à
em
phải tách riêng làm một cái Zalo để để
mà truy vấn có một cái để hiển thị thông
tin thôi U2 máy phay bị thông tin với
lao
à à
CaC2 I
ở đây này cũng có số trang rồi nhưng
chưa có tìm kiếm trở Tìm kiếm thiếu tìm
kiếm
khi kiểm tra nếu có
Ừ thì mày in ra
Ừ dạo này cho các hơi cửa vậy
anh Bởi vì À cái này ông ạ
Ừ Ông kiểm tra đây nói chắc rằng nó có
dữ liệu mà ngờ đúng không em nhé
anh mất rượu
các anh luôn có dữ liệu rồi
Ừ ông ạ
anh không thể cho mặc định cái này nó
trống hay gì đó Vân gì đó được nói cho
cái này luôn có dữ liệu anh có đoạn nó
sẽ bị thừa lại đúng không
à à
em hẹn thừa đấy
trước khi ông một phát ông vào trang này
luôn ông Ông không vào từ file bên này
thì nó sẽ không Không đi ra có thể thế
ở biển tục hết ý
à à Lấy từ file này ra t
sự phân tranh
Anh quay làm khá chi tiết ở Phương tranh
này hiển thị ra cho màu mày đẹp này
Facebook qua rồi
vì vậy mỗi lít rồi Tiếp theo bên nào
Em thử Christmas
I went home
à mà tổng hết cho mục Ford cũng được
em kiểm tra xem à Nếu mà có thì chấm a
nếu có in ra không để chấm
Ừ đúng rồi Nhiều
Hồi trước tôi cũng làm ở chỗ này đó là
một một form theo cái form sữa và form
form thêm đôi khi nó giống nhau nên cuộc
chung và trong một phom được
À à biết cái đấy không cho báo đỏ bên
Line há miệng ông Ông thấy nó vẫn bảo đỏ
đỏ lòm ở bên bên của tôi không đứng yên
là ngoài việc đọc biến nó thử nhưng mà
nó kiểu gì nó sẽ bảo đỏ một vài cái thôi
không có chán lắm
à Còn nếu không thì ông phải tắt cái bão
nọ đi luôn ở trong file này khi mẫu kiểm
tra hết Xong hết rồi Thế là tôi không
hẳn đã tôi khuyên mày ông như thế nhưng
mà
bể về xong rồi ông sửa Cốt nó lại không
báo nọ không cảnh báo nữa thì nó hơi sai
nhưng nói chung và báo ở đây nó chỉ nút
tương đối mà mình hiểu được nó vẫn đúng
là được thường mình sẽ tắt nào đi kiểu
này một là không báo tại dòng này không
báo dạy pha này luôn đấy hay gì đó đừng
có tắt hạn bây giờ được
à à
Ừ cái cây nhiều bạn Nếu bạn nó không
biết thì cách này cũng ở để mày đi xô ra
này nhưng mà thực ra thôi mình học Cháu
dùng cái này chẳng biết được cái này gì
không dạy các bạn nói em nghe chị em một
cái tắt bè thôi Đến khi nào sang đón Hay
nó không có tắt hơn gà không cần có tầm
này
Em
hãy biết con mình được khai báo biến nó
thôi à
à à
ở phòng này sắm ít lên lại kiểm tra xe
máy chuyện là như thế nào nữa mà Một là
để sửa hay
đấy thì thực ra là cái đồ ăn hay các bạn
sẽ như này các bạn thấy có cùng chung
một cái một phòng ngủ được bây giờ không
cần phải cầu kỳ quần áo chân đế này lắm
a note 7 nó phân biệt nhau qua mấy thớt
mi hót post sẽ là tạo Còn mấy hộp bút
thì sẽ là cập nhật lượng khá ổn đã đỡ
nhiều mến hết rồi chỉ có post đây phó
thôi có vỏ két đâu nhá Nhưng mà về sau
sẽ có một cái in phút ẩn nữa là mấy thớt
nó sẽ hợp cũng là một cách
Thế
Hiển thị giảng review luôn kìa chị nhỉ
Em về chưa test tụng với bộ này đâu Nên
thôi chắc cũng phải ổn thôi à
chị xem nấu chao
khi hạ truyền vào trong mạng lỗi không
in à Hấp dẫn nhỉ
Á đù định dạng này à
Ừ ok
ở ngoài videsh các cầu kỳ không ạ
ở cái đoạn dùng pdo kết hợp với gọi là
piper
thì thế này thì nó sẽ khó tránh được mấy
cái liên quan đến lỗi FBI dễ sinh tránh
bị hack
à à
xe điều hướng điều hướng có vẻ ổn rồi
anh được
Ừ nhưng mà
Ê mày ông tôi tôi dậy Nếu một kiểu mày
ông làm rồi không biết nói gì đây Đúng
cmas rồi nói kệ đi nhập ổn rồi 56
cha mẹ ông xem xong đừng có tự ái nhé
ở
đây ok vừa nói xong ông kia tự ái rồi à
anh đón một thì mếu không có gì tự ái cả
đối với một để chỉ đơn giản là mình cố
hết sức của mình và làm được những cái
mà mình mình đã dậy như nào mày cũng làm
được như thế tốt rồi còn hai mới đúng là
bước ngoặt theo kiểu là ông nào nó nó là
trình nó rất nhiều cơ
Ừ nó nó mới thể hiện độ lịch trình hơn
và nhìn qua là biết được mức lương hôm
nào thì lên đến
gấp đôi không có để ăn trẻ ổn rồi họ có
thể đi làm rồi mà không ạ à
Ừ
thế thế nên là cậu đón hay thì mấy ông
sẽ đến lúc mấy ông có thể tự tùy người
ra đi lại cũng có thể làm lương người ta
cao hơn mình Thế là mình tự ti rồi còn
đoán một thì vẫn chưa thấy được điều gì
cả mấy ông thấy ở trong ngày cốt như này
ta sử như một cốt kiểu như thế này nó
chưa là cái gì
anh đến đón hay rồi chúng ta biết mặt
nhau sau không ạ
ở ngoài tác ra hẳn thư mục Delete như
thế này thích sinh
anh
tự Bắt đầu thấy ông mày cứ đi còn xác
đấy
hai thí sinh là gì ăn bếp à Không để làm
đêm à
Ừ nhỉ nhỉ
Ừ nếu cứ cố thế nào ấy
a Switch aspeed vides lại còn chấm TP
tôi đến chịu đấy
ở
cái đoạn này chưa quen nghỉ như đoạn này
cốp từ của tôi đúng không sợ gì hết á Em
đọc được báo thức một cái nhé ready
I Swear
I would i i
vị trí tác để mà cắt
cắt thẻ
Em hãy cắt thẻ ATM ở đây thôi không chặn
được mấy kí tự đặc biệt
Ừ cũng được
chữ kí tự đặc biệt này ông Chị nhắn thêm
xuống nháy nháy đơn nó chết rồi Dạo này
nhá ơn
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi Có phải ông ở đây họ bạn kiến
thức mà gà
Ừ không hẳn là để mà khoe mẹ mày ông đâu
Tôi không nghĩ mình cũng vào đây mất
thời gian thế có chị Khoe mà là
à mà là kiểu người ông vào đấy mạnh củng
cố ấy Nói chung là cũng ở để mà tôi chấm
đấy để mà tôi chỉ có mấy ông tôi nghĩ có
vài ông ở đây còn rõ chúng tôi nhưng mà
kiểu gì được người khác đừng nói khác
chấm cốt tôi cũng thích lắm miễn phí có
ông nào bảo chấm cốt tôi cho chùm ngay
liệu vợ rebisco đây ngon Ông mất tiền để
vì cô đấy Đúng tục đùa à
khi tôi chẳng biết được là ông ấy trang
Index của ông ấy đâu cơ
đoàn em Trang Index của mày đó
ở tampa
em chịu thử vợ xem nhóm mãi nếu ông cứ
làm cái gì dị
thường không Hay làm này đâu
Ừ ừ nghĩa nhóm này hôm trước không vào
được thì phải
ở
đây là nút nút đăng nhập luôn ở bên trái
nút Hủy luôn ở bên phải nhé Không phải
người vợ nhé Ừ chắc trêu
Khi Sếp à Còn thủ từ sếp nữa
à à
vì nó có khi không được
cuộc thi vào thẳng đi xổ số Đắk Lắk
anh không tìm thấy ngoài không tin thấy
vì ông ấy tách hẳn ra nhưng em
khi tôi bắt đầu chịu đấy
Em không biết cái vợ
trang ngoài vào để ăn mì view cái amin
view à
I am in view More
à à
I shall not find a
anh alo alo xin lỗi xin lỗi sẽ gọi mình
cứ bị đấy thỉnh thoảng cậu
anh không biết các bạn bị không tội bị
dính của ai
cho mấy phát rồi
à Quên mất mình đang ở trong thư mục nào
áo sọc 55
ừ ừ
à à
em hết rồi tôi chấm 6 à
35 thì sẽ là có ích
à à
Anh xin lỗi xin lỗi xin lỗi à
Ừ ừ
thế năm mình cho qua rồi cũng phải năm
thấy ổn rồi Nó năm vừa nãy đúng rồi bây
giờ xanh 6 đúng rồi 6A
A6 Tôi vẫn đang vẫn đang không là được
mà ở đây đồ án đã đồ án
sau đó đến admin mới đến
I am in view
Anh xin lỗi xin lỗi
Ừ vợ tôi à
Hai
chạm tắt này giả ạ
à à
xin lỗi kết nối đúng ạ
và tôi hình chưa chạy lại đã cho biker
ở công ty chế biến access à
số 8 Viettel post Viettel grease
em chịu mấy ông ấy Park
à à
à à kiểm tra Quyền à Ok kiểm tra Phú Yên
Anh vừa cho mặc định quyền bằng một đi à
ở một con màu gì luôn kể sản phẩm này
được
mẹ chồng hơi dị
bạn lại làm Bà làm theo kiểu mô hình mới
với xe chắc thế là tách thành đi ra bạn
có router rồi Mẹ làm cái router với bạn
điều hướng thì ra kiểu nhà trông thực
giao diện à màu mè như này rất là không
không hẳn là tốt lắm nhưng mà về cơ bản
thì tôi bảo không đánh giá giao diện
không ạ thì nên là thế này uống khá hội
rồi Xóa đối tượng bạn xa với con ma hơi
hơi công công nghiệp quá nha Xóa sáng
giờ này Xóa nhanh được nhiều rồi nhưng
mà hơi sai sai được à Hôm trước của bạn
họ thì mình nói luôn này
à à đợt đó là ờ ờ
ạ Bạn ấy bảo là em không xóa được sản
phẩm thì mà nằm ở trong mà
bạn hóa đơn rồi bởi vì nó do Bộc khối
Ngoại đúng đúng là các bạn phải kiểm tra
vụ là nếu mà sản phẩm được đặt rồi các
bạn thực ra không được phép xóa
anh không được phép sàng nhé em
cho Biti's toàn Converse Nike có một cái
bịt ở dòng cái trang này
gì
hả Hu cốt 10 gỗ cũ cốt mới rồi chứ không
được à Ông không đẩy main đúng không tô
kéo có mời rồi mà
306 vừa mới đầy Cốt Đây này ạ Ừ tối mới
đẻ cún
Chúng tôi ăn con thông Tây ở tôi kéo hết
Cốt về rồi mà
à à
ở ngoài cái truy cập Cốt về bị lỗi này
cũng chưa mà mày không tồn tại nữa à
à à
em có hết các thứ mà à
ừ ừ
anh hỏi xem qua đã à
Em thử thêm này cho bộ mày nếu thế giỏi
phết của mình tiếng rưỡi rồi
em gửi hồi mới chấm được với nhau để ông
sẽ thấy à chấm mấy ông ra lâu lâu phết
đ.g.đ các thử nguồn cả bg.pp cũng được
em không cần phải nghiêm ngặt cho nữa
khi dùng quý khách chuyển hàng nhưng mà
thôi để chắc chắn dữ liệu nô nó ngoại
anh kia mấy ông kia đừng nói chuyện trên
giao diện nhé Tôi bảo bỏ qua giao diện
đi cơ mà ạ
à à
anh em quan tâm tính năng không ạ này về
ổn rồi
khi được phép nghỉ có về nhóm mà hôm
trước thiếu hôm nay thấy ổn rồi ngắm 7
Ừ chắc tớ 57 nhớ không lầm là có bạn nữ
làm như thế này à
Thế hả Hôm trước không chưa cây thư mục
cơ hôm nay đã chia rồi ổn hơn rồi khó
hạn chương mục là sớm luôn
nhà
hàng Paris ở xa
đi tìm chuyện Tìm kiếm truyện tranh như
vậy
anh Duyệt à anh cứ sợ khái niệm
em có khái niệm duyệt ở đây rồi mình
không nhớ Có vụ này đấy Tí mình xem lại
cho nhóm này
đi
làm để mặt Phương Trang cái này nè Tổng
hợp một cái file riêng ở hợp lý hơn Vì
nhiều file nó cũng sẽ dùng cái file của
phấn trang điểm ngay à
anh địt luôn dismissed để thông báo được
Ừ ok
Em thử cập nhật trên mạng
ô
ồ email tiêu đề nội dung này kiểu này
hấp dẫn hấp dẫn các bạn làm giá xịn rồi
đài
nên dùng axit đang thực ra nó cùng tác
dụng mắt tại tổng cục đấy nhưng mà S8
trịa để kết thúc còn đai đôi khi nó đôi
khi nó sẽ thông báo lỗi đấy Đúng nhỉ Tao
đây cũng là kết thúc mày để tôi thử cha
đang vs axit pp xem cái đó khuyên gì nhé
Đây bài thử này dụng khi mà có lỗi gì đó
đến nay
cách tải cách cách thủy hội Nhưng mà
thường nó để sử dụng dừng câu lệnh cả
có ai
à à
các axit ở từ suy bay từ hell
anh đều cứu giống nhau
sự khác nhau và khác nhau ở ngôn ngữ
khác
ở đại ca như thế
anh nghe thôi thời cá ở không cần phải
sợ nay nếu mà nó không chức năng vẫn
giống nhau đến sẽ không còn là chưa nếm
vợ trước khi đang là giống kiểu so với
sát Trần kiểu gây ra hiển thị ra lỗi thì
mình phải sửa à
chưa cập nhật
em thành công sữa thành công ok
à à
nữ ca sĩ mẹ Cốt lại lỡ ổn rồi
bí mật nữ làm các cẩn thận phết nhóm 9
một mình ông dài mấy ông Đón một mấy ông
làm hơi hơi dài
Ai biểu đồ thống kê quản lý sản phẩm của
đã có biểu đồ thống kê được
Ừ thôi sợ bỏ qua
ôi tôi vừa rút lại rồi ông cụ khác phải
trong một thứ thư mục này ông này cũng
phải chị phải
khi tách tách mấy file này ra những mục
con nhé rồi thật
có gì ram tách hẳn ra card đồ họa tới
hàng ra tới ngày ông giờ gửi xe quá rồi
luôn được với từng nói rồi Cái này liên
quan cấu hình chỉ có một cái bảng cấu
hình thôi không tách ra như này chết tao
bao ngày thiết kế như thế nào nữa thôi
tôi nhớ là tôi có duyệt nhóm nào cũng
database kiểu nghe đâu nhỉ
cơ sở hữu nhược điểm không mở được cả
trong free Fire
a cho tôi không hiểu cho nhóm là của ta
bây giờ luôn xem nào
a checker
gì sai sai đấy thế cũng bắt đầu thì sai
đấy
nhóm này phải sửa lại rồi không nổi
anh không không không nên tách ra hạn
bảng như này đương nhiên là mỗi cái
thằng có một cái thông số khác nhau như
thế nào mình không cần tách ra như này
anh không còn Mã như này hơi sai này Hôm
trước rồi Tôi nói rồi đó là kiểu Nếu mà
còn thêm một cấu hình nữa rồi thêm bạn
nữa không không không ai làm ngay cả nó
sẽ là
nếu một mua sản phẩm có nhiều cấu hình 1
Cấu hình thu nhiều sản phẩm thì nó sẽ là
nhà thôi sản phẩm này
cấu hình này
để mã này nó sẽ mãi sản phẩm mã một này
cấu hình sẽ có mã này
tên này đơn giản này thôi sẽ là
a mã làm một số tiền ra nhãn sau đây là
cấu hình sản phẩm chính hãng
sẽ gồm mã sản phẩm
mã cấu hình và giá trị
Nghe thời sự đài 114 dễ hiểu 4G đi Chị
sẽ hiểu được 4G RAM đúng ạ Không không
không ai làm phiền ai cả còn nếu mấy ông
muốn thêm với một cái chuẩn bộ nhớ 2
dung lượng bớt là như này thì ghi thẳng
vào trong cái giá trị là được đến lúc
mới in ra nó sẽ in ra Không sao mình sẽ
ghi hết vào trong cuộc giá trị thôi Cái
loại tấm nên gì đâu cũng đi hết rồi đây
là sự tuổi hai này màn hình này
Đây là mã sản phẩm rất là một cấu hình
2ibs 4k nhà được Có sao đâu đó Ngoại
đừng có tách nhiều cột nhiều bạn như thế
này bởi vì về sau thêm một cái cấu hình
gì đó là sự là cậu là màn hình 5D này là
không thêm cái gì nữa chưa chắc chắn vì
sau kiểu định sẽ có thêm một vài cái
thêm cảm biến vân tay thì chả là con đây
à à
chứ không phải làm chi tiết đây phải con
cái gì nhỉ chắc chắn ở phía sau kiểu gì
cũng sẽ có thêm một ngày cái ở đây thiếu
thì ông Định làm nha thêm bạn nữa không
Không có ai làm thì cả
em
chạy rồi nhóm này nhóm này mà bây giờ
đang xem nhé thì sửa lại cho mình gấp
cái đã về nhé Nếu thế và sửa lại code
đấy mình mình cháy hết mình mình không
duyệt cái đã bơi như thế này một là tôi
chấm thiếu mấy ông hay là ông tự sửa ra
bay của tôi
I got all mà chấm thiếu rồi ra tội không
nhớ được hết nên là mấy không phải nhắc
tôi Tôi không nhớ được hết thật rồi có
nốt lại tất cả nhóm thì có cái gì đâu
quên quên khi cái đấy cố định ghi cái
đấy rồi nhưng ghi cái đấy ít ra nhi ở
trên cái danh sách tổng như này Đấy nó
hơi bị gợi cảm có nhóm khác nhìn vào
thấy nhóm Long khiếu nên tôi không đi Ở
đây An Hội tội quên mất
thu quên mất cả nhóm nào đang Tiến độ
nhà rồi hãy ra là kiểu sẽ có nhóm mà tôi
bị xót mấy ông cũng phải thường xuyên
nhắn tin nữa tôi nhắn tin cái tôi thì
anh trả lời luôn rồi Xem
nhóm này cậu này nhưng mà chấp hành nhóm
kiểu như ngày đó bây giờ lại bắt buộc
phải sửa bắt buộc phải sửa
à à
số còn lại tối mới có mấy có một tí em à
em chưa Đây cũng là cứ cho là một trải
nghiệm của mấy ông thấy nó tội nó bị
dính một phát rồi mà đồ ăn một cậu bị
dừng phát đồ ăn ai đỡ dính phá rồi đó
thầy sao bà lại
Bởi Hồi đấy tôi một phản ứng tự ý sửa ra
đây nữa này ra kiểu thầy thấy không gian
bây giờ có nhiều phải Cốt lại hết khá
nhiều cái phải đập đi xây lại sự ra toàn
anh hơn
Ừ
đấy rồi liện hệ luôn tách thư mục ở đây
ra nhé
có ai kiểu gì cũng rẽ phải hiểu được cái
cảm giác Cốt lại hay làm gì đó thôi I
Ừ đúng rồi Cốt lại thật là mình nhớ cốt
được các thông số thứ và ít bạn hơn mình
làm nhanh hơn
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra tách hẳn bạn riêng em
làm hơi khó đấy nhá thì làm này không dễ
đâu nhé Làm này khó hơn việc là ông còn
nhiều bạn đấy như bà không chỉ phải đi
rất là nhiều bạn không thì ra cũng phải
chọn chọn cấu hình
nhưng mà Thì thấy toàn bộ sẽ lấy các
chuẩn là nhanh nhưng còn làm hai kiểu
này nó khó hơn nên
Hình như là nhóm này cần thì có thể nhắn
mình rồi mình sẽ livestream
để mở cốt cho bạn các bạn các bạn này
mấy bạn hiểu
vì thế kế kiểu này nó khó hơn đấy ạ việc
tách nhiều bạn kia nhưng về sau thì các
bạn sẽ thấy nó dễ dễ còn ý hơn thế còn
đi hơn và mình thêm được bao nhiêu cấu
hình cũng được
chú ý mình làm như thế
à à chi tiết kiệm tôi Cho xe mấy ông
hình như tôi vẫn còn đi đâu vậy ạ
Ừ
thôi tôi vẫn còn lưu để tôi tôi làm cái
trang bàn máy tính cho sinh viên thôi mạ
để tôi cho mấy ông xem qua
a website that
à à
ở
nhà mini
xem bên A
Ừ cái này là tôi làm nhanh thôi
Có ai dùng lọ lem mà em không không hết
Hùng là được mà Không phải đăng nhập
thật
em
sợ đi
anh nói chẳng nhiều tên nữa nhà lo mày à
à à
anh làm sao
a website
3000 hay nhầm rồi
site.net web
Ừ cái đấy cái gì nhỉ
thứ hai tôi xóa xử rồi nhỉ
ừ ừ
Ừ thế để ở xem lại Vắt
cái À razzil mà em nhìn vào thể xóa
a website ngôi sao mà nhỉ Hình như là
không phải tôi rốt mới rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ vợ đâu một tí
khi hack được Brazil hotgirl tôi không
ngồi đây
ờ ờ đợi tôi đợi một tí thôi tôi đẩy nó
lên internet ngoài mạng rồi tôi đăng
nhập nó ở ngoài mạnh vậy
thôi Nhưng giờ xóa sửa trên máy máy tính
cá nhân cái ra tao bây rồi
à à
ở góc chào mình sập rồi
ở thời trang đáng sợ nhé
à à
hôm nay vẫn còn mà
Ừ nếu đừng vào nha và không vui không
ông kể
thế này có đấy làm tối sinh viên tương
đối rồi đấy tôi làm tuần
ô cửa sổ thêm sản phẩm này
ở đâu đấy ta làm cái kiểu dạng kiểu như
thế này nó chèn thêm cấu hình trực tiếp
lưu lại trong này thay vì ra Tạo Hoàn
bảng riêng nhưng mà đại khái Cấu hình nó
có thể thêm kiểu như thế này
để thêm mới một cấu hình này
a màu đấy mặc định màu màu đỏ em ạ Có
tăng để full đấy để phòng á Không
ai kiểu ngay phải thêm kiểu thêm kiểu ví
dụ màu Blue thì tiền nó sẽ chênh lên như
thế nào thêm phí hay không có sự thứ với
tôi làm không Tỳ Vết
thế nhưng đại khái thì hội Đây đây là
chuyên nghiệp hơn rồi nhưng mà ông hiểu
gì tôi một sản phẩm nó như cấu hình này
nó khi nó là kẹo ít nhất là vài kiểu
kiểu tách ra thành như thế này có thể
chọn được một lúc là mua sản phẩm thêm
một sản phẩm mình có thể chọn nhiều cấu
hình cùng lúc đây làm cách mà không thì
ông phải nhảy sang một tác riêng để mong
chọn cấu hình không phải tích tích vào
điệu lắm cái này ram như nào có RAM 20
gì đó thì nó ổn hơn
á không lỗi về mình lười mình cũng chẳng
Cấu hình lại thư mục đó tích ở đâu vậy
cái này thì ra là có phải để mà làm gì
đâu để đang nghe sinh viên mà kệ
à à
xe máy lại khái nói như thế
khi lá cây bài toán sản phẩm cấu hình
ảnh lằng nhằng phết nên nhóm này Mà làm
thấy chưa hiểu lắm thì có thể nhắn tin
hỏi mình nhé á
à à
à Anh nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm
Ừ ok
ở nhóm 11
E52 như thế phải phải cậu
có sẵn
em kiểm tra lại sau phải đánh dấu lại
kiện lại sau
ở nhóm này năm 11
khi tôi còn chẳng nhớ nhóm nào đã nhỉ cơ
nhóm này hình như ở nghỉ ngơi vậy đúng
nhỉ
Hôm nay nghỉ chưa nhỉ
em
không nhớ ở nhóm nào nhiều lắm
em gửi xem nhé Nhớ có nhóm nhắn tin tôi
vào nghị rồi
à à nhóm này chưa chưa chưa làm xong OK
ở nhóm 12A
ở nhóm 12 như xin nghỉ rồi
E52 Huynh yêu xin nghỉ rồi
Ừ ok Tại sao nhóm 12 đi
số 53
số 53 hôm trước đâu
khi tôi chấm thêm hai ba nhóm nhớ nữa
thôi hôm nay không chấm hết rồi xin lỗi
hả Học zzas tuần tuần sau họ nhé 357
em có có mình cho các bạn được phép dùng
really nó thử coi thử mà được phép dùng
thư viện không phép dùng Facebook thôi
Ừ thôi bảo không được phép dùng mô hình
cho em mấy ông kia ôm ở mỗi Huỳnh về rồi
ra ô mô hình về đây ôm bất kỳ cái
Facebook về không sao nhưng mà đón một
thì không nên làm phức tạp đến nỗi thế
cũng được những những bạn cùng nhóm ấy
ông mà không hiểu về đấy Sẽ thấy khó
người khác một cái đôi dậy
anh vào đâu để học vào
anh
vào kênh YouTube này để mà xem mình lái
Simi Dậy thôi mà mình không có mở khóa
học ở đâu
Ờ
năm 13 vì thế nhóm 12 tặng xóa đi ạ ạ
Ừ nó sẵn rồi à à à
Ừ ông ấy cũng sẽ mất cốt sợ lắm em gái
nhìn cô trong nặng mày
I am i này
có cách nào gọi Becgie lấy chuẩn cái
riêng ngọn Ok Ok chị lại
ô tô nhiều anh nghỉ à
ở miền Bắc này
phụ trách pháp Viettel
đề kiểm tra
à à
ừ ừ
đi
tìm kiếm
vi
phạm đô la la
ở đôla các tvshop
ở trong cùng thể loại hơi gì nhé
ừ ừ
ở cùng thể loại trong thể loạn và kết
hợp với tìm kiếm tìm kiếm được còn nếu
không có tìm thêm mỗi Tìm kiếm gì đó
không có không tìm kiếm theo thể loại ra
nhỉ hơi lạ
Ừ cái này thì con là nếu thế phải tách
ra thêm cái nữa lắm
Ừ ok
Nghe danh mục kinh điển
đi tìm kiếm chỗ này sửa lại chính tả lại
nó
khi bé ok rồi
Ừ nó đi bên à
anh em đi
chị xem xem mẫu xác chết rồi sao
em chuyển mã để sửa chả có tí pha chết
rồi này
ở trong ngày ôn đâu
có
hai nhóm nữa nhá Hỏi nhóm nữa mình tạm
đi hôm nay dài quá
Em có cách nào cầm đèn chạy trước ô tô
không
Anh Hải à
ở
thời gian mình có bạn khá nhiều bạn hỏi
mình người mấy cái trăm pin rồi mình thì
gửi bướm một mức tương đối rồi chúng
mình chưa động ở bên công nghệ bên bộ
phim hay lót nhạc được mà Để mà giải
thích được nó xong k a
Ừ mình cũng chơi mức kiểu rọi được như
thế anh nhiều Anh cậu video cơ giống
kiểu anh tôi tôi đi có dạy Đà Nẵng mấy
người đấy xíu sao
đánh đề đấy câu gì anh mình thấy các câu
gì anh ấy Họ xong anh rảnh chạy được mày
nghĩa chưa tìm hiểu được nhiều công nghệ
thế Mình chỉ ở gần như không Mình thực
lập trình viên gọi là
từ tương đối cứng tay thêm tí rồi Bên TP
bà là gram thì ra bạn hỏi mình lấy cái
đấy bây giờ được này em kia thì chả được
này
và mình là mình gọi nhau cái gì hay thì
mình chia sẻ được các bạn thôi Thực ra
là mình cũng không phải là cái gì biết
nó nhọn trong anh cũng tin này có nhiều
cái mình mình không làm đến thì mình
cũng cũng không phải tìm hiểu hết được
A và
mình cũng chẳng qua tính của mình hay tò
mò triệu
anh vào mấy cái Trang đấy thì xem tò mò
dự đoán thế em công nghệ nó là gì đoán
thôi chứ thật là nhiều trang thì tra
Google rất khó để biết được thực sự công
nghệ của nó là gì trừ khi các bạn làm
rồi mình thì làm thì mình làm lại chủ
yếu lại chưa từng làm thì mấy cái bên
đấy bởi mình không Hương thú và một cái
đang kiểm tra xem phim gì cả nhiều ông
ngồi trước nói thật là thời gian thì ông
làm trong phim phang Xem phim Đặt quảng
cáo kiến mức tiền đấy nhưng bởi vì mình
có đam mê với tiền đâu Thế là mình chẳng
làm mấy cái đấy mình mình làm mì tôm
Facebook mà đúng không ạ
Có đấy mình làm tung Facebook và chắc
bọn hay các thứ nếu hỏi tôi cái đấy thì
chả được họ tôi mấy cái tôi chưa từng
làm gì Bây giờ tôi chém ra nó cũng chửi
thôi chứ
số 53 off
thông tin nóng Việt Nam nha nhỏ 15 sao
U15 khiếu cứ thử xem nhé
U14 trước đi
I mean
a post
để tạo thành một thư mục support Index
ok
anh chẳng nói gì cả đúng không Không gì
mà đúng
ông
xã rồi footer Ok rồi à
ở Tab này thứ và steady
à à
nhà đất
cô
Hạnh rồi dùng gas Quế Cái gì ạ
a
Google dịch của tôi bức tranh
tô màu gì đấy à
Em
hãy
hỏi bận ba lớp luôn ok Ổn mà còn mát
à à
kiểu nhảy hiển thị ra ngại không biết
bấm khói không à
ừ ừ
10 ảnh đại diện thì anh đại diện luôn ok
Ê mấy ông giải trí độ lại chỉ cao đấy
cho tôi nhắc cái này nhá ông nhớ được
thì nhờ nhé Không được phép xóa à Xin
lỗi không được phép xóa
về superman superman không được ra xa
nhau
dự án Min không được phép xóa đương
nhiên sẽ thật chặt được phép xoay cả A
và không được phát sáng ở bản thân nữa
nhé tôi chưa ông nhớ được Nhớ kiểu gì
tổn sẽ hỏi vụ đầy đó
vị trí lô
ba lô khác
amin cần được phải xóa rồi ok
Ừ
mẹ dùng để thế này
chưa cập nhật
vì chúng cũng rất dài thôi
từ thiện how i
Ừ
đúng rồi Super mịn thì mình đừng nói đấy
Giả sử gia sư ở nhá Bây giờ có một bên
nào đó thuê các bạn về để làm trang web
bán hàng người ta đóng muộn thì đầu tiên
là các bạn sẽ không không không không có
đăng ký luôn cả Super mi mà nó ngọn
không ai làm tình anh đăng ký cái thì
thường ông sẽ lưu lại cái cày cái super
admin vào luôn trong đêm bị datapes họ
đã phát tốt đấy ông ạ cùng lắm là về sau
Thứ nhiều nơi nó sẽ có cơ chế như thế
này à
Ừ nó là
ông vứt cho họ một cái tài khoản như thế
là sự Superman rồi mật khẩu 123 ạ sau đó
thì ngay từ lúc vào thì ông kiểm tra xem
làm mật khẩu là 1 2 3 thì sẽ yêu cầu
phải đổi mật khẩu để người ta đổi mật
khẩu Đông ạ người ta sẽ đổ mật khẩu rồi
à
Ừ rồi có như là để Tại sao người ta phải
đổi mật khẩu để mà tránh việc về sau tự
như ông vào trang của người ta thôi ông
ạ Đấy
đấy là một cách nói chung mà sẽ không
nói chuyện là ngay lúc đầu luôn sẽ có
một tài khoản superman và và gần như là
họ sẽ tự giải quyết việc là đổi thông
tin cá nhân để mở việc hôm nay vào được
nữa Tại sao họ sẽ thêm nhân viên nuôi
thường cái thứ hai đó là
Ừ
nó cũng là kiểu vẫn cho tài khoản vẫn
mặc định như thế sau đó thì ông bảo 13
là hãy tạo một tài khoản Superman mới đi
rồi rồi rồi ông sẽ hỗ trợ xóa cái tài
khoản Super win cũ để nói chung là không
họ họ hiểu thêm mới xong rồi họ họ gần
như là cái mới đấy là của riêng họ đúng
không ạ Chị mật khẩu họ biết thôi ông sẽ
không ra được nữa đấy nó như thế
à à Ừ chứ không có tính năng đăng ký
Superman không ạ Bạn có muốn làm chủ bên
tôi không không không chuyện đấy rồi
đúng không ạ
ở nhóm 14 em về ổn thôi này từ nha Ok
Ừ đúng rồi dùng sister được Sido mình ạ
đoán hay kiểu gì mình sẽ dậy các bạn qua
hết toàn bộ những thấy gì có thể biết
bao gồm khá nhiều ở bên Dream cơ bản
nâng cao có hết
xe nâng cao thì cũng dùng từ nâng cao
thì không đúng Nói chút à đề án 2 thì
toàn bộ những cái gì mình biết mà thực
tế thực về đi làm ở sẽ như thế nào mình
sẽ dậy hết được bạn Những cái gì có thể
dạy bảo là chất trước khi chọn lọc hết
của mình Tình Thù hết giả hết Nói chung
nhà Bây giờ cứ coi như là mình dạy các
bạn đoán web này từ hồi à
từ tháng 10 năm ngoái vậy Nói chung là
tầm mà
cho mình dậy lauriel có những thứ có
chán chê đến từ thằng ma tự sáng 3 cho
đến tận tháng 6 hay tháng bảy gì đó đi
ông ạ Nói chung còn chưa đầy một năm mới
ông ấy thích lĩnh hội được hết toàn bộ
những cái kiến thức của tôi trước vậy từ
hồi tôi đi học lên bây giờ
đi tìm mấy ông thấy việc học hỏi người
đi trước nó như thế sẽ học nhanh hơn bù
lại rất nhiều kiến thức đấy hẹn mấy ông
cứ sẵn sàng tâm lý trước đi Có gì thì đi
học ạ Ông này có hết trong một chung mù
à
nhớ nhấn mày chưa sửa vậy khi họ biết
duyệt nhó Mày đưa lại cho tôi xem lại
tin nhắn nhắn mày phát
à à
ở nhóm này hình như nghỉ hết rồi
ở ngoài nhà mày nghỉ hết rồi
họ đậu xanh
à à
Ừ Ok thế thì ỉa chấm nốt nhóm 16 nha
Anh ở tội Hi vọng mấy ông bảo một vài
ông nào đó mà và được công ty tôi
ở Chư kiểu công ty tôi đang thiếu người
kinh
anh không biết tuyển đâu ạ
ở các dạng buộc cần có của 1
anh hỏi câu hơi lạ dòng buộc Đây là dòng
bộ khó Ngoại đúng
Ừ mình cũng nghĩ việc dạy song song cả
bên lao ấy nhưng mà thôi Mình muốn dậy
từ đầu đến cuối cho khóa này khóa này
của mình mình mình vẫn chưa biết được về
sau có bạn có nhiều người lạ mình để dạy
khóa tiếp theo không nhưng mà nó xong
khóa này mình mình muốn dậy từ đầu đến
cuối trong một bạn từ từ không thứ từ
không biết gì cho đến biết vì không ạ
anh đi làm ở công ty làm công ty stop
cũng ở ở Hà Nội thôi
anh sim đi à Có bạn nào mà có nhu cầu
thời sự và bạn mới biết làm theo này hay
biết bên A review Rét này và nói chung
là bìa sát nên là bây giờ đang hơi thiếu
người nếu mà thiếu người để thiếu người
gọi nhà ở
ở Tuy nhiên ở cũng phải có một là có trí
tí
- tuyển ông nào vào chơi chơi chơi ông
nạn bỏ đi thì không có nên không ạ nói
chung mà
Mấy ông có có ý định kiểu làm được các
nhân tố của các thứ
ở đâu tài không ạ thì cứ nhắn tin qua
Facebook cho tôi hỏi tôi sao rồi tôi gửi
cho dì đi mày không xem nhẹ Phải phỏng
vấn nữa nhưng mà
anh nói chung là thức bây giờ đang tuyển
cả thôi trước thì phải tiện người bắt bộ
làm được Còn bây giờ thì chuyển cả người
à Thật là khách sợ được đào tạo dân
ý nghĩa là có chí thì ta dạy còn chạy
được
chị Xuka là em ở đâu cũng được mà bây
giờ tôi vẫn đang làm tại nhà thôi Quan
trọng là mấy ông nào được hay không rồi
Em email có ngồi chung trong mảng anh à
anh ở dưới ca mấy cái ràng buộc về đơn
giản mà mình chưa hiểu ý bạn lắm xong
mua cửa là ràng buộc hồng ngoại này dòng
bột unique mua vài cái thôi
Vì sao tự nghệ hỏi mét về Xem phim có
Giang bộ với hình ảnh hơi lạ lạ
à à
anh nói chung công ty mình thật là
khuyến khích nên kiểu gần thì vẫn có
nhiều cái và nhiều cái tốt hả nói vì tôi
từng nói kiểu sếp sếp tài trợ rất nhiều
cái cho anh em
ở ngay đây này anh cậu kiểu ship cho ghế
thôi xong rồi
lên văn phòng được rất nhiều đãi ngộ tốt
nên mấy ông làm ở xa chắc nó béo bị
thiệt đã ngoại giao ạ Và nếu mà sang
nhiều người chết hả mày Không phải được
giao tiếp được thường xuyên nữa thứ ngày
nào họp cái thứ
trong nhà ở
Ẩm Thực ra là sếp của tôi còn còn là
thuê hẳn hai căn hộ ở trong timecity này
để mà cho cho nhân viên ở Nếu mà giờ sự
bạn ở quê lên hay gì đó cơ Mấy ông mà
làm được mấy ông cần nhắn được thì mông
chuyển qua đây ở luôn ở trong cái Căn Hộ
Trong đấy được thế mày hay không
khi chết của tôi đã a số khung số cả tôi
người đang trong này đấy ạ
à à
anh sex thu hạn căn hộ ở cho nhân viên ở
mạng xong rồi thuê hẳn cả
người nấu ăn cho nhân viên luôn nhân
viên thì phải rửa bát
thuê cả người Thực ra còn đang nghĩ việc
mua hạt máy rửa bát không mấy ông cơ
mua lại nha Cho thực có bình nóng lạnh
rồi nhưng mà lười quá hơn nữa gạch xếp
mua máy rửa bát xếp tôi chiều cực chẳng
thiếu gì vậy
ừ ừ
à à
ở bên mình làm view View nấc
nấc nấc
Chị nói là with music tất cả Lazio các
bạn thuyết thì ra nhảy sang nó cũng
tương đối thôi nó vẫn là giống nhau mà ừ
Ừ mẹ không cưới hả hướng dưới kiểu gì
năm sau mày ông quên rồi bạn Tôi buồn
lắm Tôi kiếm cái khó vãi Ngày này giờ
thiệu chiếu cực cái mấy ông vẫn nghĩ là
ngày này nhiều người học ngon thiếu cực
Dạ sinh viên thôi những đứa mà học được
đấy những đứa mày đang theo ngành ấy bỏ
làm ở gỗ mà chẳng muốn chuyện đi đâu cả
kiểu kiểu nữ an phận thôi chỗ nạn cố đãi
ngộ tốt nhất có thể mà
nó cứ mơ mộng Thôi đi làm đi được là
nhiều nơi rất thẳng là tôi khẳng định
nơi này đang đãi ngộ rất là tốt hơn
nhiều nơi thật nhưng mà những chỗ kia
thì bọn nó cũng áp phận mà vẫn cũng đưa
đôi
anh
ở lại làm ăn của tôi không mấy ông ấy
bảo tối đa cấp tôi chấm nốt nhóm 16 nhé
á
Ừ nếu mà Mấy ông nghe thế Thật ra tôi
thấy tôi từng làm vài công ty rồi tôi
lại đấy thứ hấp dẫn thật như đùa
ờ ờ năm 16
a hotel mất rồi sao à
anh Bởi vì tôi đang muốn chuyển nhánh
có thể dùng ý à
em không biết anh ánh đúng không bé
không biết đúng sai nữa
cho
tôi cho sang đây này sao ý
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ tối vẫn nhánh bếp bố phải có nhiều
nhanh thế
ô kê nhạc rap
Ê mày ông có gì mà ông cứ nhắn tin tôi
qua Facebook nhé Để tôi gửi gì đi xong
rồi Phỏng vấn thứ
U23 nhỏ với vợ làm chi đa Ok nha à
e hèm đồ
cho Androi lên đồ gì Xóa đậu xanh thêm
đồ ok
em không có sửa không có thêm lúc đầu cố
định luôn à Ok
con lắc đi xem
ở miền đất này
đã sửa xóa kê
à à
anh nghe Chắc chưa pallet nhà may vừa
nhắn tôi thiếu đếch có Hữu nhóm này mình
chỉ em cơ bản xem em sẽ xóa thôi thức
được
Á đù rồi
a57
216 Ok với nhóm sau trả buổi sau tôi
không phải nhầm không phải bố sau Tí nữa
chấm Sao về tôi Mệt quá Tự nhiên tôi
muốn ngồi chơi
người ăn rong buồn ngủ cực à
Xin chào Bữa hôm nay tạm kết thúc đây
thôi hôm nay tâm sự được khá nhiều rồi
những cái câu hỏi các bạn hôm nay không
chạy được cả một câu hỏi bộ trước nữa
thì chắc là buổi tù bao giờ trả lời bác
đầu từ buổi thứ ba tôi tôi nói đấy thì
bộ ba tôi sẽ dạy có tí gọi là nhưng
không phải nâng cao nhưng mà nói chung
mở rộng hơn một tí về gj để mà làm được
những cái kiểu trang trang có thể và bết
nhanh này săn mồi hiển thị thông báo mù
me này bị thông tin biểu đồ cái thứ màu
mè Nói chung rất nhiều cái bằng seri làm
được mình sẽ ra đấy
thì thì
Ừ bắt đầu tuần sau nhé nó chưa Khi nào
mà tôi cảm thấy dậy được Cũng tương đối
hết chuẩn bị hết thứ để mà dậy cho cái
khóa này rồi chung là sau tết sau tết
Chắc là gần như hết thứ dậy thì mình bắt
đầu kiện lại kiểm tra chấm và tôi còn ăn
cấp nhất mình xem có có buổi bảo vệ thử
không của vịt nhiều nhóm bảo vệ thử
thách mất bán bún buổi hết rồi bảo vệ
thấp nữa
tôi sẽ Nếu mà bọn Nếu thế thì tôi sẽ cho
bảo vệ khử nhưng mà một vài nhóm thôi
tôi sẽ đang nói cho tôi sẽ cân nhắc một
vài nhóm trước sẽ bảo vệ thủ trước đi
dùng từ trước đi để xem thế nào xem ổn
không anh cho sẽ một lời cho tất cả nhóm
bảo vệ thử ai ở Chị mua vé nhóm bảo vệ
thôi Vì vậy tôi sẽ xem à
Ừ rồi à Rồi sẽ bảo vệ thật có đủ thứ nữa
Nói chung mà sau tết sau thế âm
Bồ Hôm nay sẽ tặng kết thúc đây thôi nha
Chào Chào mấy ông nhé á
ở đây
à quên
à à